Hello 大家好，我是今年第一次开始关注Utnb的Eddie。
Hello 大家好，我是今年测了不少越野跑鞋，
但是只是跑了一场越野比赛的概念。
这里是二期的。
逼谈概论。
我们两个也要来聊Utnb。
对。
这合适吗？这合理吗？
肯定是不合理的。
别说去跑了，我们甚至之前都没有怎么关注过这个赛事。
这感觉Utnb离我们好远好远好远。
对。
这50公里的比赛我们都没跑过。
所以感觉好像我们没有资格来说这个赛事吧。
其实我们身边跟Utnb相关的一个是最近越野跑鞋的这个合作特别多。
就是因为Utnb马上要到了。
所以各大越野跑鞋品牌都希望在Utnb这个赛事的期间或者是赛事之前发布自己的新款跑鞋。
另外一个呢就是也是刚刚出来的新闻吗。
Fuga刚刚官宣新之类成了他的好像不是代言人的。
不是代言人，共同发起人。
好，这是一个什么样的决策。
专门为他创立的一个身份吗。
Tidal都是自己给的呀。
现在品牌的Tidal都是各种各样的。
因为代言人这个Tidal太重了。
很多品牌其实就不太愿意给，因为会有一定的风险嘛。
而且短期的合作一般都不会给代言人的。
那他也是借着Utnb的这个试头吗。
就是在Utnb刚刚结束的时候就冠训了这个新闻。
其实我想聊Utnb跟他没有任何关系。
是吗?
对，因为我在做这个功课的时候我还不知道这个事情。
其实我们前段时间就一直在聊这个问题啊。
为什么各大品牌都要在夏天发布自己的越野跑线？
对于中国大部分的区域来讲，
夏天都不是一个非常适合越野跑的时间。
一个是天气特别热嘛。
越野跑那个距离又长，爬山又大。
而且受度相对于路跑来讲还会更慢一点。
对。
另外一点就是山里的这个植被疯狂生长。
徒步的人基本上也是秋冬季去徒步比较多。
夏天山里就很少有人去。
很多路都已经被植被给盖住了，
根本就没有办法进行越野跑训练。
主要是因为我们跑的山去的人确实也不多。
如果你是在像吴夕余山或者是乡山的话，
可能就不存在这个问题。
那那个路就开得比较好。
这个也不能算是最严重的问题。
最严重的问题就是？
蛇。
对，蛇是一方面。
我们前两天去山里的时候，
山里的那个牧羊人就让我们不要往上爬了。
最近已经发生了好几起就是人被蛇咬上，
还有被蜈蚣咬到。
蛇虫书翼，
像是有毒的这种蛇虫书翼，
在夏天山里特别毒。
如果发生这种情况也是比较危险的。
最严重的就是天气问题了。
包括我们经常去爬的那个山，
它都在上山的那个入口处，
象征性的拦了一个塑料绳嘛，
然后还写了一个通告说极端天气禁止如山。
因为今年这个天气确实不太正常。
很多山里一带下暴雨就容易出现泥石流啊，
或者落石啊，
或者塌方那种情况。
总之就是夏天在我们这里是不太适合越野跑训练式的。
对，北方乡山那种地方，
它其实可能跟侠穆尼的这个天气比较类似的，
伪度比较高，
然后侠穆尼它是海拔也比较高嘛。
所以直背相对来说比较少一点，
然后天气也没有像我们这边这么湿热。
所以八月份对他们来说可能是一个比较好的越野跑的季节。
但是在中国的大部分区域，
夏天确实没有那么合适。
但是各大品牌还是会把越野跑的上市时间安排的这个时间点。
对，就是因为UTMB。
对，当UTMB这一波传播开始起来的时候，
我们就找到了答案。
一开始我们其实都想不明白为什么，
我们要把越野跑的上市全部集中在夏天。
对。
其实我想要聊UTMB还是出于一个营销的角度。
我比较好奇一些问题，我想要去找到答案。
其实从八月四号开始，
在小红书上就已经发起了一个，小红书的官方啊，
就已经发起了一个世界偏爱也如此的话题。
我感觉到它是集全平台的流量，
只要适合运动户外相关的流量都在往这个话题上倒。
而且在这个话题里面有一个子话题，
就是侠母女的日雨夜，就是关于UTMB的。
这个话题好像也是这次小红书与UTMB的官方话题。
我想要知道的答案就是平台给了这么多流量，
所有的品牌全部都翁过去了。
大家都做了不少的动作花了不少的力气，
运动员也都去了。
最后大家得到自己想要的回报了嘛。
出于这个原因，
我才去收集了一下今年UTMB，
所有的这些你现在看到的信息。
这个收集的过程就一旦开始就收不住了，
因为信息非常非常的庞杂越跑赛事，
本身也非常的有意思，
资料就越找越多越找越多。
那我就觉得说，
哎，我们还是可以两边一起来聊一聊这个话题，
虽然我们感觉离这个比赛真的很遥远。
那我们可以以一个圈外人的角度来看一看，
UTMB这个赛事。
那作为一个圈外人，
首先关注这个赛事最大的障碍就是它的名字。
对，它的主别。
它为什么要叫UTMB？
很多人可能连这个名字是啥意思都不少。
对，UTMB，我觉得相对来讲还是更好理解一点的。
它叫Ultra Trail,。
然后用法语，你给我不知道怎么读吗？
类似于德，英语里德这个词的意思，
就是Ultra Trail的Mount Blanc,。
翻译过来就是环博朗荒超级越野赛。
但是UTMB它不仅是这个赛事的名字，
它还是这个赛事里其中一个组别的名字。
因为最早就只有这个组别，
把这个组别变成了赛事的名字，
它又不是最长的。
如果你是计时算成字的话，
它就是最长的组别。
它的距离大概是在100英里，
每年可能根据路线的这个调整稍微有一些浮动。
所以除了UTMB这个组别之外，
它还有CCC和OCC，
这两个组别也是大家关注过比较高的，
因为它也是这种竞技性很强的组别。
大家看到这两个名字可能就不知道啥意思了。
其实都是地名吗？
对，它不像是国内这些比赛都是用距离来命名的，
比如说百英里百公里五十三十，
这样大家更好理解一些。
但是CCC和OCC它其实都是三个地名的首字母连起来的。
像最后一个C都是终点的名字，
小穆尼那前面的O和两个C分别是起点和中途途经的一个地方的地名。
所以如果你像我们这样是圈外人的话，
你看到这几个字母，
看到这几个组别的名字就已经蒙了。
对，这首先就会造成一个关注赛式的障碍。
脑子里都要转一下，
就是每次看到CCC五脑子里都要反映一下这是几公里。
那除了关注度最高的这三个组别之外，
还有其他的几个组别，
那名字就更难记了。
比如说像TDS，
它虽然距离没有UtnB那么长，
但是它的难度非常的高，
一共要跑145公里，
然后它的爬升达到了9500多的爬升，
这个组别就是以囤率很难注称的，
所以能够在这个组别站台其实也是很艰难的一件事情。
那还有一个比UtnB更长的组别，
就是PTL。
对，PTL比较特别，
它是规定一定要组团完成的，
最少要有两个人，
可以有两到三个人组成一个团队，
它的总距离是300公里，
这个组别它是没有排名的，
这么长的距离里面，
你是要自补给自导航的，
就是要你虐到极致的一个感觉。
那还有三个组别是MCC、YCC和ETC。
MCC就是为志愿者还有当地的居民，
还有赞助商设立的一个组别，
你可以理解为它就是一个亲友组，
它的距离是40公里，
YCCY就是亲上年组别嘛。
所以ETC就是门槛最低的一个组别了。
这可能也是出于一些商业化的考虑，是吧？
是。
到晚你看到我们今年国内哪些人去跑了ETC，
你就明白这个组别它的意义是什么了。
对，它的距离是只有15公里。
对，你说从中国到那边翻山越岭的，
然后过去跑15公里，
而且它15公里的关门时间是4小时30分，
就哪怕是我们这个水平去参加也处处有娱乐。
比我们水平更入门一点的去参加也是处处有娱乐。
对，我感觉就是说你平时没有怎么练过的，
应该也不会被关门，
除非你当中碰到伤病情况。
对，所以我说它是更多出于商业化的考虑。
那为什么UTMV在越野跑圈它的地位这么高？
我觉得首先可能是因为它这个赛道规划的比较好。
穿越了三个国家，法秘睿。
因为2V4山，侠穆尼这个区域可能本来就是越野跑，
还要说特别喜欢，也比较集中的一个区域，
越野跑的氛围本来就特别好。
就跟Kona一样，为什么Kona变成了铁3的一个圣地，
可能也是那边本来就有一些爱好耐力运动的人，
然后在那个地方办了赛事，
才会慢慢的影响着逐渐扩大，
然后吸引全世界的这种爱好者去参赛。
第二就是赛事的路线规划结合了难度，
结合了这个优美的风景，
以及各种不同类型的赛道，
可以让大家有一个比较好的参赛体验，
而且还可以夸三个国家，
这确实也是一个比较特殊的地方。
第三个我觉得可能是商业化做的比较好的，
因为他现在奖金也是逐渐升高，
今年的总奖金好像是达到了20多万奥远，
就是所有的组别加在一块，
然后最重要的UTMB这个组别，
男女冠军的奖金是达到了2万奥远，
所以在越野跑这个，
以前都是相对来说用爱发定的这样一个赛事里面，
他的奖金也算是比较高的，
而且他还在越野跑赛事里面做到了可以视频直播，
这种在其他赛事里是很难做得到的，
那视频直播又进一步的提升他的商业价值，
因为大家能关赛了，
能关赛就会有更多的人关注，
那可以让赛路上有更大的一个曝光的机会。
虽然说UTMB在国际上，
他一直被称为是越野跑的电堂级的赛事，
但说实话，在过去我对他的这个印象一直都很模糊，
直到今年我才发现说，
其实国内很多人都去跑了这个比赛，
不只是说我们知道的这些运动人，
所以他在越野跑爱好赛事里，
他还算是一个大家都非常兴致省网的一个赛事，
但他的准入门槛其实还是挺高的，
这点跟Ironman又很像，
就是你要先参加UTMB的一系列的赛事，
是,
你要积累跑时，
你要有积分，
你要有跑时，
对,
然后你去报名参加这个比赛，
中间的概率才会更高，
所以就是难嘛，
你要参加这个比赛很难，
这个比赛要完赛也很难，
难上加难就会让更多的人有这种挑战的欲望。
今年的UTMB参赛注册总人数是已经达到了一万两千三百零六人，
男女的比例差不多是七三坎，
男生是战七层，女生战三层，
然后你刚刚讲到的三个最经典的组别，
UTMB CCC OCC加起来,。
一共有六千六百一十九人，
UTMB这个组别就有两千四百六十五人，
大家来参加这个比赛，
很多人就是笨着要跑UTMB这个组别的，
而且我们今年中国过去参加比赛的选手也已经有四百九十三人了，
我觉得这个数字也不算很少了，
毕竟这个过去的成本还是蛮高的。
所以这些人里边有多少是自发报名取得，
有多少人是拿到了品牌的赞助取得呢？
自己还是要有这个名额才能够去和品牌谈赞助，
因为品牌直接能给名额的我估计只有ETC组别，
就是最简单的15公里的组别。
也就是我们刚才说的最短的15公里的那个组别。
对，这次有两个品牌，
不愿儿童是邀请了两位娱乐明星、
演艺明星去参加了ETC组别。
一个就是复改邀请的赵易欢，
他好像最近在运动圈的这个动作特别多，
前面还去参加了hirox，
现在又去跑UTMB，
UTMB的ETC组别，
这个一定要说完整，
我觉得他们对外边说的时候，
不会说自己跑的是ETC组别，
只会说我参加了UTMB。
那还有一位呢？
还有一位我就不是很熟了，
只听过这个名字，
但是这个人我真的有点对不上好。
然后您他已经算是演艺明星里面运动气质比较足的一个了，
自己也一直有在玩冲浪啊什么的，
然后他这次也是参加的ETC组别，
他有把他的成绩公布出来啊，
3小时45分42秒，
嗯还可以吧我觉得。
好像说爬升比较大，
所以我觉得能在关门时间内跑完对于演艺明星来说已经是不错的。
对,
对而且是他的人生首隐嘛，
采访视频里有问他说，
你之后还会有跑越也跑的计划吗？
他就是本能的停顿了两秒，
然后糊弄了一下。
这个坑我们每次跑完越野菜的这个第一想法是一样的，
每次跑完都说再也不来。
对,
这个时候如果说我下次还要跑，
我觉得真的有点不真实吧，
那个时候肯定是非常痛苦的，
休息两天你又会缓过劲了，
然后又开始上头了，
对就觉得这个比赛还是挺有意思。
我相信对他也是个很难忘的体验吗？
对啊,
因为时间越长，
你能想到的更多就是这个比赛里好的地方，
坏的地方都被自己选择性的忘记了。
不会忘记，
但是会觉得那我也挺厉害的，
然后杨又宁是洒罗蒙请过去的，
那你有关注到这次有哪些品牌他在Utnb这个期间有一些动作的吗？
我觉得凡是跟约保相关的品牌都有一些动作，
只是这个动作大小的区别，
这里面就包括几个类型嘛，
一个就是送运动员过去比赛，
肯定是希望运动员能拿成绩的，
第二回就是和一些博主的合作，
那第三个就是在这个期间去发布一些关于新品，
或者是未来要发布的新品的信息，
最后一个就是在当地他们也会做一些品牌的活动，
比赛的选手媒体都可以去参与品牌组织的各种活动，
然后耗一点羊毛啊什么的，
第一反应你能想到哪个品牌做的哪件事情，
或者哪个品牌找的哪个博主？
我觉得首先可以把这些品牌分三个类型嘛，
第一类型就是真的是特别重视，
就是真的把Utnb当个事来办的，
甚至是把它作为自己全年宣传营销的主战场之一，
那第二种我觉得就是常规动作了，
也没有说为Utnb特别计划一个声势浩大的宣传活动，
第三种我觉得就是好像不是特别重视Utnb，
对我们说的都是国内的市场营销，
就这里一定要特别声明一下，
因为Global层面其实只要是有越野鞋的品牌，
大家都是大作特作的，
但是在国内的情况其实就像刚刚你说的，
是有很明显的不同的，
对不太一样，
那你刚才问我首先能想到的肯定就是ACG了，
是吗？因为谣妙吗？
第一是因为谣妙，第二是它发的新品，
你还是对鞋比较感兴奋，
那肯定吧，
而且它是让谣妙穿了这双新鞋，
对，这鞋的名字叫Pecco Juice，
我不知道是不是这么毒的，
但是按照它的意思来讲应该是这么毒的，
酸黄瓜汁，
好像就是越野炮者特别喜欢的一种偏方，
喝酸黄瓜汁来补充自己身体需要的一些盐分也好，
或者是微生素也好，
这不就是我们的渣菜吗？
有点像，
那我如果是中国的越野炮品牌，
我马上就做个鞋叫渣菜，
它那个鞋的配色也是从酸黄瓜汁的领感，
黄绿黄绿的，
而且它的设计理念也跟之前的鞋不太一样，
好像说是没有放碳板，
可以适合更多人，
对，那这次也是这双鞋第一次保望，
离它正式上市好像还有很长的距离，
至少还要等一年才能看它正式上市，
明年上市这个鞋，
所以你看ACG还是挺聪明的，
对，这是一方面，
另外一个也是因为谣妙这次确实成绩还算是不错，
对,
特别是在中国选手里，
应该是最好的成绩了吧，
唯一一个战坛选手，
对啊,
谣妙是以18小时48分24秒，
拿到了CCC组别的女子的继军，
所以Nike以前谣妙真的还是比较成功的，
当然跟品牌的运作肯定也是脱不开关系，
是,
因为谣妙好像是在6月底就已经去了欧洲进行备赛，
那中间也是参加了西班牙的那个阿兰谷的赛事，
通过这个来熟悉地形，
所以它应该算是备赛时间最长的一个中国的选手，
我觉得ACG对于谣妙的重视除了备赛之外，
你去看一下这次各大品牌在官方账号上给这些国内的运动员，
安排的公关内容产出，
谣妙绝对是所有的运动员里面就是待遇最好的，
专业的拍摄团队制作专业的物料，
不管是平面还是视频，
第一就像我们以前说的一如既往的速度非常快，
第二就是质量做得非常好，
就有些品牌自己的运动员甚至没有任何的信息在官方账号上入处，
所以相比之下我觉得ACG这一点还是对运动员非常的尊重，
不过我觉得谣妙自己应该对这个成绩还不是特别满意，
因为他的目标应该是拿冠军，
毕竟之前是拿过冠军，
对，24年和25年谣妙都是OCC组别的冠军，
所以它是有这个实力的，
对，而且中间过程也是比较曲折，
它好像一直都是排在第二，
然后我们看到一个短的片段，
第一名在一个铁道铁轨的路口被拦住了，
因为要等火车过程，
然后谣妙是追上了两个人一起通过的那个路口，
一直是第一第二，
结果在最后阶段被第三名抄上来，
第三名直接反抄了谣妙和前面那个选手拿到了第一，
所以谣妙是最终取得了第三名，
他因为膝盖好像在这个过程里面也非常的疼痛吗？
他自己还说这次想试试不用账，
也是他的一个新的尝试，
他在上一次那个西班牙的比赛里就没有用账，
就是因为那次他觉得自己不用账状态非常的好，
所以他这次坚持不用账，
比完赛他也说他觉得不用账是一个正确的决定，
那他腿的问题跟帐没关系吗？
这个就不好说了嘛，
对啊,
他自己觉得没关系，
对,
那ACG其实在这一次的整个赛事上也算是有所掌握的，
他们赞助的运动员罗人获得了OCC组别的女子组的冠军，
有一位首次参加UTMB组别的选手也是穿着ACG的Ultra Fly，
拿下了一个继军的好成绩，
所以我觉得ACG他在越野跑这个赛道上面的发力，
应该算是有所成效的吧，
尤其是在这样重要的赛事里，
他也是拿到了成绩了。
所以我觉得ACG在UTMB有这么大的动作，
可能也是跟Nike目前的这个声音状况有关，
对,
因为他在其他方面做的都不是特别的，
是呀,
声音一直是在持续的下地，
所以他也是急于找到一个新的突破口，
他甚至把他的产品的发力方向都集中到了越野跑这块，
是,
很少看到Nike把越野跑作为他的一个概念性的，
有突破的这种创新的产品的一个手法的舞台，
所以也是表明Nike今后几年时间确实可能是要在越野跑这块投入大量的资源的。
所以ACG还是可以持续关注一下，
其实我统计了一下，
用数字说话，
我觉得这一次有一个品牌在UTMB上，
真的算是猛猛发力，
你可以猜一下是哪一牌子，
你说哪方面比较猛，
各方面，
对,
我就这么说吧，
我等会抱一下蔡明，
大家就能知道这个品牌没少花钱，
那肯定就是刚才你说的，
请明星去的两个品牌体，
Fuga和Solomon,。
对,
那这位选手就是凯勒什Fuga，
他这一次真的是把自己品牌的野心就写在了脸上，
这次凯勒什战队，
包括国内外的运动员，
一共去了30个人，
后台都没有去这么多人，
这三十位选手来自14个国家，
而且最后CCC组别的男子的冠亚军，
全部都来自Fuga战队，
讨论度比较高的肯定是CCC组别的冠军嘛，
因为他已经是42岁的老将了，
是一个意大利的水坝守护人，
就这个职业也比较有意思，
然后他是以10小时二是1分48秒多得了第一，
他是不是守水坝了，
就自己在跑，
绕着那个水坝在跑什么，
绕着圈儿去守那个水坝去观察，
然后有这个可能，
就很多人都觉得说42岁，
你可能没有办法再发挥出一个最佳的竞技状态了，
但是他就是用他自己的成绩证明了，
其实年龄有的时候真的不一定是一个障碍，
也是深深的自力到了我，
那这个毕竟也是一个特例嘛，
那肯定了，我也不会说，
我也可以老当一壮，
我也没有这样的自信，
另外值得一说的就是，
Fuga这次找的国内的这些运动员，
首先UTMB组别是由张伟强去出战的，
罗灿华和杨健健他们是出战了CCC组别，
那OCC这个组别就人比较多，
管游胜，赵家居，赵苦，王如晴，
全部都是参加的OCC这个组别，
那另外就是刚刚说的赵一欢，
他也是穿着Fuga的全套装备去出战了ETC组别，
Fuga为什么没有选择在UTMB这个舞台上。
冠选和秦之内的合作呢？
你把秦之内也送去UTMB吗？
来不及吧，可能，
好，你当时还没有谈好，
也是啊，反正赵一欢也去跑的ETC，
让秦之内也去跑一个，
他就算不把这个比赛跑完，
他去那两个项也好，
没有没有，时间没有卡上，
然后另外Fuga也是和一些博主去做了一个付费合作，
那应该是博主自己有了这个名额之后，
可能和品牌这边谈那些赛事营销的合作吧，
然后在侠牟尼Fuga还组织了观影会，
因为我也没有去到现场，
我是看人家说的，
他是用影片的形式去展现了朗图体育，
旗下的几个国内的大型赛事的风貌，
就是把我们国内的乐园赛的一个经济时展现给这些国际上的乐园跑爱好者看，
可能也是希望以后未来会有更多的国际的乐园跑爱好者也来中国参加我们的乐园赛吧，
那另外也是一个重磅信息，
就是Fuga的欧洲首家指引店也是正式的入驻了侠牟尼，
它是快闪店吗？
不是，是首家指引店，
去年做了快闪店，
然后今年它是正式做了指引店，
所以我觉得Fuga还是挺值得聊一聊的，
首先就是这个名字，
以前大家知道它都是叫凯勒什，
但是凯勒什它的英文其实是钢人波西风，
这个名字如果用在乐园跑上就不是特别合适了，
如果你是户外是登山，
用这个名字可能比较恰当，
但是在乐园跑圈虽然我们中国人念凯勒什不觉得它有什么含义，
但是老外看到这个名字就觉得有点奇怪了，
所以它也是把Fuga这个名字单独给它拿了出来，
它的乐园跑这条线以后就单独叫Fuga了，
好像都不太会跟凯勒什放在一起，
对，写稿子的时候都要求我们不能说凯勒什EX330必须要说Fuga，
那还有一点就是Fuga的乐园跑鞋，
它都不叫乐园跑鞋，它叫跑山鞋，
这点也是跟其他的品牌区别很大的，
它们的社群叫跑山帮，
但这个其实我一直没有明白为什么一定要非常严格的规定说，
Fuga就不能叫乐园跑，只能叫跑山，
其实我没有很理解这件事，
我也不是特别理解，可能是里边老板有一些特别的这种想法，
因为我觉得这有一点很tricky的事情，
就是说大家以后去看小龙书上的笔记，
但凡这篇笔记里只说跑山不说乐园跑，
它一定是上班，就是这个道理了，
大家也不会看得这么行，
那还有一点我觉得很值得说的，
就是我觉得Fuga是目前国内品牌都在重金压住乐园跑的最重要的原因，
因为榜样的力量，
对，这个倒不是说它的生意企量有多大，
我觉得很多综合性的品牌可能没有觉得它是一个有威胁的竞争对手，
这个我们之前也是有切身体会的嘛，
老板就直接跟我们说，
你做专业跑步就算做到亚瑟市的体量又怎么样，
也就是2311的生意，
那我觉得Fuga，你不说它的那个户外登山那一块，
只看乐园跑，
我觉得它的乐园跑这条线应该距离亚瑟市的2311的体量都还有一些差距，
所以为什么国内品牌现在都去投乐园跑，
倒不是说我看中这个体量，
更加看重的是Fuga他把价位拉上去的这样一个成功案例，
对,
凯勒时包括Fuga可能是国内这些品牌里边从一个平民品牌逐渐把价位提升，
成为一个高端品牌里边的为数不多的成功案例之一，
甚至有可能是唯一的成功案例，
是,
这些大品牌当然看着眼红啊，
因为所有的品牌都有一个高端品牌的梦想，
都想把自己的这个品牌形象包括价位段跋高，
但是有些品牌都冲了多少年都没冲上去，
心愿也是可以理解嘛，
因为毕竟大家很多品牌都还在这个性价比的赛道里面疯狂的卷，
其实我们也说过，
这样卷下去真的很不利于公司的发展，
利润太微薄了，
对,
就是根本就经营不下去最后的结果是，
所以肯定是希望自己能够把这个价位段拉高，
能够有更多的利润空间的，
虽然我们看到各种社交媒体上有可能人都在骂开了，
是啊,
作为消费者，
对,
没有骂，
就是说以前动不动不便宜，
怎么没几年的时间现在这个价格自己已经高攀不起了，
而且产品的质量并没有说非常明显的弃生，
还是跟以前差不多的东西，
尽管有这么多消费者在吐槽，
但不能否认的就是他冲高确实成功了，
对,
他现在这个价位依然有不错的销量，
而且店铺也是越开越多，
那我觉得这个情况，
国内其他的那些大品牌看着肯定是非常眼红的，
是啊,
当然他这个冲高成功肯定不光只是因为越野跑，
但是其他品牌你要去深入研究，
也没有那么容易研究透，
他也不会轻易的把自己成功的详细的这个策略公布出来，
那可能大家能看到的最简单的就是啊，
因为他是专注于越野跑，
那他冲高成功了，
所以我专注于越野跑，
我也可以冲高成功，
大家就会把这个思路简化，
然后得出这样一个简单粗暴的结论，
这个我觉得平台和咨询公司也是功不可没的，
因为凯勒什他在别的方面肯定也是下了功夫的，
但是他在小红书上越野跑，
写产品推广的投入，
这个一定是你很容易就涉及到的一个信息，
小红书也一定会把这个东西当成一个案例，
东秀给所有的运动品牌，
就希望他们能够照着凯勒什的这套打法在小红书上去花钱，
一些咨询公司他也会把它包装成一个所谓的现在中国什么运动发展趋势之类的一种白皮书，
然后去东秀给各大公司，
平台和咨询公司一发力，
大家脑子里面就被种下了这样一个概念，
就是凯勒什通过推越野跑协成功的晋升了，
而且他的生意确实涨了很多，
2025年凯勒什的营销已经是接近40亿元，
增速超过了50%，这是多少品牌，不敢想的事情。
但这个是整个凯勒什品牌的营收，
应该不是越野跑协要先。
没关系，但大家就会这样简单地去画等号，
因为他的越野跑协推得很成功，
品牌形象提升，价值提升，
然后他的营收也提升了。
我觉得他的营收里面那些户外的服装肯定还是要占大附，
一些羽绒服啊，冲锋衣啊这些东西。
这个我觉得我们今天就不详细展开了吧，
今天我们还是聊由TNB，
总的来说，Fuga在这次Utnb上至少国内团队，
我觉得是大发力的一次了。
也是非常明显的，就是让大家看到说，
我们现在就是要在国际的舞台上高调亮相。
所以为什么我对Fuga的印象没有像SG这么深，
因为他这次没有什么让人眼前一让的新产品。
大家穿的还是EX Pro、EX330，
有一个EX ProG，就是他的EX Pro出了一个瓦套。
炸了一个瓦套，这个也是目前越野跑协的一个趋势了，
就是把防沙套整合到这个写字里面。
我觉得很有必要。
但这次Fuga的运动员里面，
其实最后留给大家的一些讨论度还比较高的，
其实是他这次运动员发挥的都不是很好。
国内的运动员，管游圣赵家居。
这算是国内的越野跑运动员里面人气比较高的，
粉丝也是比较多的，平时比较难整活的。
但是这次就跑的都比较一般。
可以说让粉丝稍微有点失望。
而且就是他们事后的采访也是怎么说。
管游圣他说为什么这次跑的不理想。
他就说这次都是大爬身，不像国内的很多山，
你可以上一段，然后再下一段，
上一段，下一段，那下的时候他就可以充速度嘛。
那这次就是连续的一个大上坡，不是很适应。
但他之前也参加过吧。
不是这个阻别之情。
然后另外赵家居吧，他也是说他喜欢以赛带练。
他在跑这次的比赛之前，
其实已经跑了好几个比赛，
他们俩都是。
管游圣基本上保持一个月跑了一次，
长距离比赛的这样的一个频率。
赵家居说他不喜欢长距离训练，
如果要跑长距离那就是比赛，
就在比赛里面直接找感觉找节奏。
国内的越远跑运动员，
不说运动员吧，
就是说他们的教练，
我觉得是不是在这个观念上面都需要重新去再学习和反思一下了。
因为我并不觉得说跑得不好，
就是因为我们中国没有这样的地形可以让你练。
我觉得这个真的很难成为一个理由。
我觉得这个是晚尊的一个说法。
其实这个也衍生出了一个讨论嘛。
我们之前其实也聊过这个话题，
就是国内因为现在所有的品牌都在投越越跑，
有资本汇聚到这个运动当中来，
那肯定就是水长船高，
运动员的待遇也随之提升。
有说法就是目前国内的这些二三线的运动员，
他的身家甚至都要超过国际上的那些顶尖运动员。
包括这次同样是福卡奇下的拿了CCC冠军的那个选手，
就是你刚才说的那个大巴管理员，
他的身家可能都比不上我们国内的刚才你说的这些选手。
那既然国内这些选手，
他不需要在Utnb这个赛事上有非常好的成绩，
他依然可以在国内拿着这么丰厚的赛事的出场费和奖金。
他有什么必要把他的这个重心完全投入到Utnb这一场赛事当中来呢？
我如果不花这么长时间准备，
我在国内再参加这个比赛，
我可以拿到更多的奖金，更多的曝光。
对,
那我何必要把鸡带放在一个篮子里？
我觉得这可能就是你到底对这场比赛有多重视，
也有可能其实大家都没有说，
我真的很把Utnb这个比赛当回时，
我可能觉得说我反正也占不了他，
我就去量个项拿个出场费，
然后我其他的比赛该跑的还是跑，
拿点奖金也不错。
这点我觉得其实也没有必要去苛责这些运动员，
因为他们说白了也就是普通人，
和我们的想法也差不多。
他们也就是把Utnb当成了工作，
当成一个谋生，一个手段。
这几天这个互联网上流传了一个笑话，
既然盖房子是为了卖，
那我都已经卖出去了，
我还盖什么房子？
对于这些Utnb运动员来讲也是同样的想法，
既然我拿好成绩是为了赚钱，
那我都已经赚了钱了，
我为什么还要努力去拿好成绩呢？
主要是因为这次大家之所以有这样的落差，
还是因为我们中国这些运动员出战的时候，
有媒体还灌了一个，
就是类似于像最强战队这样的一个。
人最多话，是吧？
不，是iTRA的那个积分最高。
所以就感觉是已经到了这个时候了，
我们要去Utnb上一斩雄风了。
就像前面说的，
我们的运动员假如人家姚妙，
之前也都在这个比赛里面不同的组别拿到过冠军，
总让人觉得我们的选手是有希望的，
万万没有想到就是在今年，
我们看到的其实是和其他国家运动员之间的一个更大的距离。
那我觉得品牌是不是也要反思一下，
就是你们签了这些运动员之后，
不停的让运动员去参加比赛，
一个月一场长距离的越野跑比赛，
他怎么可能能在Utnb上跑得好？
但问题是品牌他要的不只是Utnb这一场比赛的曝光，
他签这个运动员要的是持续不断长期稳定的一个曝光，
所以我当然需要你多参加一些比赛了，
因为就像我刚才说的，
这些品牌他的目的不只是越野跑，
这么一个非常小的圈子，
他是希望通过越野跑来帮助他拓圈，
来帮助他把品牌冲击高端，
所以他当然要持续的一个曝光，
让圈外的人也能注意到他签的这些运动员。
圈外的人根本没兴趣，
圈外的人可能只会看赵一帆和姚佑尼拉。
只要我的那个关号的素材可以发就好了，
我每场比赛都有运动员可以站台。
我一个圈外人，我干嘛来看你关号？
那凯勒石他是怎么让圈外人关注到的呢？
大量的博主和推流啊。
对啊，就是这个意思嘛。
最近有什么比赛模模品牌的哪个运动员，
他又站台了又拿了冠军，
这就是这些博主他的素材，
否则你如果一年只有一个UTMB成绩比较好，
那其他的比赛你的运动员都没站台，
甚至都没去，
那这个曝光的时间长度肯定是不够的，
只有这些真正热爱越野跑的人，
对越野跑非常了解人他才制造UTMB这个比赛的含金量，
他才制造UTMB站台和国内其他比赛的站台，
不是一个级别的事件，
但是很多人包括一些自己跑越野跑的人，
他可能没有这么关注UTMB，
他都不会有这么清晰的一个认识，
所以这种长期的稳定的曝光，
肯定是要超过你在UTMB这一个赛事上的曝光。
而且我可能就算是为这个运动员做足了比赛的准备，
到了比赛的时候，
他可能还是会因为各种意外拿不到理想的成织，
这个风险太大了，
就像你说的我鸡蛋还是不要放在一个篮子里，
这个怎么说呢，
就是我们其实也就是看看热闹，
但对于很多狂热的越野跑的爱好者而言，
看到这些运动员表现全线不佳，
肯定是我有点失望的嘛。
对，那你觉得明年这个状况会改观吗？
我觉得会有一些运动员，
聪明的运动员，
或者说是更加有自己的一些目标的运动员，
他可能会调整自己的一个训练和备赛的节奏。
我说实话，
就如果你是广邀圣的粉丝，
你别骂我，
就像广邀圣和赵家居他们这样的运动员，
我觉得他们已经带有一些网红的属性了，
所以我觉得他们不会去调整的，
依然还是要吃他们已经吃到的这些流量。
其实跟大众这样的也没有太大的区别了，
对，之前不会玩流量的时候，
广邀圣也吃了不少苦，
后来发现了流量的密码会玩耿了之后，
他也获得了很多关注，
他的商单也变多了，
也能签到很好的品牌了，
他不会再改变的，没有必要。
所以我说就只有等国内这个跃跑的风慢慢平静下来吧，
等这股潮水退了，
可能这些精英运动员才会把精力重新放到，
我要在重要的赛事上拿成绩这样一个目标上来，
因为如果资本都不关注跃跑了，
那你如果没有一个拿得出手的，
非常硬核着成绩的话，
你可能就根本拿不到赞助了。
就回到几年前的样子，
对，你还是得靠成绩来说话，
是,
所以我觉得看长远的话，
如果你是一个职业运动员，
那追求更好的竞技表现，
就是你唯一的目标。
特别是最近刚刚出现的一些年轻运动员，
比如说你之前排过的，
小书,
对,
就我还是挺希望这些年轻运动员不要太急功尽力，
而且我觉得有很多网上的一些他们的粉丝就会说，
人家也要吃饭啊，
人家也要养家啊，
但是你太小看现在国内的这些品牌，
愿意给运动员的费用吗？
而且还有一点，
就是那我关注你，
我崇拜你，
我是你的粉丝，
不是因为你要养家啊，
那我随便关注一个打工人不就好了，
每个打工人都在养家，
可以来关注我们吧，
我们也活得很辛苦，
对啊,
我关注你是因为你的成绩非常好，
你训练非常刻苦，
你有一定的精神属性，
你有很强的感招力，
你取得的这些优秀的成绩，
你刻苦训练这个态度，
可以感染到热爱之下运动的人，
这才是大家关注你的原因，
那我觉得未来我们的运动员和品牌在谈些合约的时候，
是不是也可以注意一下，
现在有很多回约可能是以出场计费的，
就是我一年出几场比赛，
就能拿几份钱，
然后站台再有额外的奖金，
我觉得这种签约方式，
其实就制约了运动员，
他没有办法真真正正的。
去为一场重要的比赛，
做认证的训练和备赛。
对，你说这个也还是要等那个潮水退去吗？
因为现在品牌更看重的是持续的保护，
它看重的不是重要赛事的成绩，
那这个潮水会退去吗？
我觉得会的，
这个我们留到大话再说，最后再说。
你别说现在这些品牌投资还真的收到了一些效果，
因为我的视频下面经常会有人在评论说，
我想穿这个越野跑鞋的通勤可不可以？
哦，以前都是说我想穿这个跑鞋通勤，
现在变成穿这个越野鞋通勤。
对啊，之前这么问的人很少了，
但是现在每一个越野跑鞋的视频下面，
几乎都会有人在问这个问题。
你没发现我们健身房，
我们一个湖北三线城市的健身房里，
有很多人已经穿越野跑鞋健身了，
有穿富尬的，有穿麦勒的，
还有穿雅瑟士的，
还有穿萨罗蒙的。
对，这个趋势真的很明显。
对，不知道以后会不会蔓延到小孩哥那儿，
小孩哥以前都是穿蓝球鞋，
后来穿跑鞋，
再往后会不会穿越野跑鞋，
你看现在泰兰尼斯都开始错越野跑鞋了。
有这个可能，
但我不知道越野跑鞋，
他穿一天会不会脚很臭啊。
也一样啊，穿跑鞋也没好到哪去。
那种泰兰跑鞋很透气的，
妈妈愿意买这个鞋，
是因为脚脖子也那么臭啊。
好，那我们再往下聊一聊，
另外一个也算还蛮用力的品牌，
就是萨罗蒙。
对，萨罗蒙毕竟是主场作战吗？
不是主场。
法国侠目的就是他在主场。
哦，你是这么理解了？
那后卡不答应啊。
就是老家老家。
对。
萨罗蒙这次让我比较意外的，
就是他不仅找了杨永宁，
他还找了一些非常tope的运动博主，
比如那个基本误害的主播毛东，
国产收音机还有王爷。
我觉得他们也算是萨罗蒙后卡，
这些品牌特别喜欢的博主。
一个是他非常的头部，流量非常好，
数据非常好。
另外就是这些博主本身，
确实它是比较有个性和风格的。
另外,
我记得他还找了一个非常知名的跑步媒体，
帮杨永宁以及team萨罗蒙去拍摄了一支长达六分钟的自录片，
比赛结束之后，
每几天这支自录片就上线了，
动作也是非常的宽。
这支自录片上线之后，
马上马上就有一堆那种视频账号做了那种二创的内容，
就是萨罗蒙最近拍了一支自录片，
怎么怎么好，
然后这个你懂得的，
我们也是做过这种内容的，
这个都是付费的公关合作。
所以你掐指一算，
你就知道萨罗蒙其实这一次还是大投入的。
那是不是为了跟ACG别描头？
因为毕竟要不要被牵走？
他们国内的运动员这一次的战迹也不能算是特别理想。
那女子组的话还OK，
就是谢文飞和齿岭杰其实都是顺利完赛的，
然后谢文飞是TDS组别的女子第16名，
TDS组别难度也非常高嘛。
但是身家生作为team散落门里面，
大家也最期待的一位选手，
这次参加UtnB组别退赛了，
他已经是第四次退赛了，
另外是人气也非常高的张伙化也是退赛了，
唐锦燕也是CCC组别退赛，
总的来说表现都不算太好。
但是也有让人很欣慰的地方，
就是海外的这些参赛选手的表现。
有一位选手这次的曝光度也非常高，
就是今年首位用一支完成UtnB组别的选手，
他就是赛伦赞助的叫Julian，
他冲现的时候也是自己给自己安排了很多戏码，
就是他是首先牵着自己的孩子一起冲现，
然后他就拆下那个椅汁倒上了香檳，
喝了一口香檳，
然后把那个椅汁横过来放在嘴前面，
好像是一个大大的微笑的造型。
那这套动作可能夹了练郎。
对，所以就是他冲现的这个镜头在媒体上的曝光就特别多。
还有一位女子的选手Nami，
他在OCC组别是以6小时8分10秒的成绩，
独得了这个组别的亚军，
但其实OCC组别这次的灌压军成绩仅仅差了3秒。
3秒?
对，你去看那个冲现视频的时候，
其实冠军冲现的时候他就在冠军后面。
就是短跑的成绩差距了？
就我不知道他在那个时候能不能就一个剑步冲上去。
肯定是前面已经追了好长一段路，
发现追不上来，最后才差3秒。
不可能说我这差3秒，
我最后一点点不追了，放弃了，
这应该不太可能。
这3秒已经是他能追到的最小的差距了。
两个人一起冲现之后，
也互相伸手及掌拥抱。
他们两个还分别来到赛道的两边，
去迎接后面的第三名。
三个姑娘一起在赛道上冲过来的时候，
就互相手牵着手。
这个画面还是非常非常地感动的。
你要说Girls Power,。
我觉得这个就是十打十的Girls Power，
就是那个画面里面三个女生，
又有坚韧的那一面，
又有作为女性特别温柔，
特别有共情力的那一面。
我们已经自己很辛苦了，
就是跑到要趴在地上了，
但我们还是要过去等候后面的继军跑过来，
然后跟他一起来庆祝我们大家的这个胜利。
我觉得这个场面还是让我满印象深刻的。
还有一个比较有意思幕后信息，
就是这次Solomon他Global的影像记录团队，
是由Courtney White带领的一个全女性团队，
里面包括拍摄和后期，
全部都是由女性工作者去完成的。
这个是有什么特别的用意吗？
Girls Power,。
就是告诉你这个你认为很苦的，
只有男人可以甚人的工作，
全部都是女生一样可以很优秀的去完成。
那他们拍的内容是只有女选手，
还是男女选手都有？
都有啊，都有。
只拍女选手，真的男选手是不是有点可怜啊。
这是他们的官方摄影团队。
不知道啊，就是Solomon他们Global，
有没有去和一些博主或者是知名的Inc上的网红合作，
让他们去跑Utnb，
这个信息我就没有找到。
就国内而言的话，
他的这个策略，
我不知道你怎么看，
就是找杨诱宁啊，
还有一些大的博主去跑。
我觉得这个还是附和Solomon一贯的风格。
因为毕竟他现在的生意重心，
也不是在约保这块，
生意重心还是在通勤呢，
实际上这块儿。
所以找一些圈外的人来参加Utnb的比赛，
也是完全可以理解的。
不管这么说，
他们还是没有放弃Utnb，
还是为Utnb这个赛事，
划出了这么大一块儿的预算，
我觉得已经是很不容易了。
感觉有一段时间，
大家都说Solomon好像远离了越野跑，
但是这两年你的明显感觉到，
Solomon又开始非常重视越野跑这个赛道，
当然这也是大事所向。
是啊,
因为整个行业的趋势在往这方面转嘛，
而他又是有越野跑抵运的，
那肯定就更顺利成章了。
那也有一些有越野跑抵运的品牌，
现在就是逆势而为，
比如Utnb曾经的赞助商哥伦比亚，
这个品牌就真的很有个性，
因为它太有个性了，
大家都在往越野跑，
它偏偏就撤出了越野跑的赛道。
那哥伦比亚已经是我刚才说的，
第三个层级的品牌了，
就是没有在Utnb有什么动作的品牌，
所以第一个层级，
就是对Utnb特别重视的品牌，
你觉得还有吗？
根据你查的这些资料，
那肯定就是官方赞助商Hokka呀。
好，Hokka你还是把它画到第一层级啊。
对，这一点我可能很多人的意见不一样啊，
因为我听了很多播客也好，
或者是大家那个小红书上发脾气也好，
大家都说感觉这次Hokka在Utnb上存在感很弱，
对，主要是因为它没有第一名嘛，
而且它的成绩好像跟前几年相比也是有一些退步。
对，Hokka战队全球的运动员，
他是派了23个人出阵，
这个数量跟Hokka比确实少了一点，
但是他也是有选手站台的，
Utnb的女子第三名是Hokka的，
然后CCC组别的季军汉斯也是Hokka的选手，
TDS组别女子的第二名Alice也是Hokka的运动员，
但就是因为没有冠军嘛，
所以就感觉差了一口气。
而且好像说在全部三个组别的60个前10的位置里边，
他的这个战彼也下降了。
那在中国的运动员军团里面，
Hokka的拳击相对来说也没有很差，
首先没有人退赛。
国内的赞助选手方面，
这个成绩我觉得算是中规中矩吧，
几位选手都没有退赛，都完赛了。
其中Leanna就是他们Hokka刚刚签的一个女子选手，
在这次是以27小时17分03秒的成绩，
在Utnb组别他跑到了我们国内的女子选手的第二名，
然后四郎多吉这次还不错，CCC组别全组第七名。
这个成绩也算是我们这次男性选手里面比较好的一个成绩了。
然后门光副是跑到CCC组别的第十二名，
另外小将雷晏他也是这次完成了OCCC组别的比赛，
就雷晏他因为参加大比赛的经验不算特别多嘛，
所以这次能够完赛也算是不错的。
对我们去年在废博教那话参见他那个见面会社，
好像说他刚刚转到越南，
以前是练田镜的，
有很可爱的两个虎牙的一个女生。
为什么我说后卡的中国团队还是有发力，
就是我有看到一些他们合作的博主的内容，
其中也有一些粉丝量在10万以上的大的博主。
门光老师好像这次也是和后卡合作的，
还有好几位博主，
我记得他们都是和后卡这次有合作的。
有些是穿着他们的装备去比赛，
有些是去参加他们和跑也越野看台三方合作的一个跑前的派对，
做这样一个落地活动在侠目你有感觉也是花不少钱。
但坦白说就是他的这些和博主合作的内容，
我要不是特地去搜我其实都没刷到，
包括他那个跑前的派对我也没有自然流里面刷到鼓。
是因为头流不够吗？
我不知道他们有没有头流啊，
就是我感觉UTMB的信息里面，
大家还是更容易被那些顶尖运动员或者是赛场上一些动人的故事所吸引吧，
大家还是来看进去表现的，
如果只是一些商业活动或者是博主的内容，
我说实话，这个博主发的内容，
他是UTMB还是崇利168还是柴谷唐斯我觉得没什么区别，
无非是风景不一样而已，我就不太想看。
因为博主毕竟关注他的人还是更多是关注这个越野跑运动的人，
所以你太休闲跟这个UTMB的主题偏差太远，
可能大家也不是特别爱看。
就他们肯定也是尽力跑的，
只是即便是尽力跑，
但是他们整个的一个状态你肯定是没有办法跟那些运动员相比的。
难得有一个这样的赛事能够让我看到这么多来自全球的精英运动员各种精彩的表现。
我真的没有必要去看那些博主发的东西。
这个我是深有机会，
我在测跑鞋的时候那个跑资和我真正放到视频里的那个跑资就完全是两孔状态，
我放到视频里的必须就是摆摆，
否则那个跑的动作就根本挫的没法看。
精英跑者的风采真的会把其他的那些素人盖掉说实话。
对，所以如果要是你来做的话，你会找明星去吗？
不会啊，
因为我觉得你找明星去跑国内的重力168和跑悠天币没有任何差别。
只要我有一个明星去跑越远赛他就有话题。
那余天币你要怎么做呢？
如果你手上没有那种非常精英的运动员，
就是他有很大概率能取得好成绩的运动员，
你要怎么来做这个赛事呢？
根据我今年的这个观察，
我们现在就要聊这种话题嘛。
对啊。
首先就是认清我们能够拿到的资源到底有多少，
假设我们根本就没有精英运动员，
可以去站台，可以去拼成字。
我还是会希望说能够在这样的一个机会面前。
把这个平台去留给最热爱越远跑的人。
这个不是说什么我们领了领了了，
赶紧去抓人来参加这个比赛来给我品牌录出，
而是在漫长的三百六十五天里，
我就要开始去观察有没有这样适合的人选了。
首先这个人他真的很喜欢越跑，
但是可能因为他的经济收入原因，
可能因为机会的原因，
他并没有去参加过有停笔，
但是是他心里面很向往的比赛。
第二就是他是喜欢我们品牌的，
他不是那种今天穿你，
明天穿他谁给钱就说好话了，
他自己就是喜欢穿我们的产品的，
并且信任我们的鞋子能够帮他完成这场比赛的，
不会有任何的勉强的。
那找到这样的人之后，
我就认认真正的学让他备赛。
所以你会去找一些草根那一种。
对，就让他备赛，帮他去记录，
就是这个人不用自带流量，
我来帮他记录他的整个备赛的过程和他比赛的过程。
说实话，
我真的不觉得我花很多钱去找一个博主，
去跑一天笔，
能给我带来很好的回报。
我目前看到的数据，
我并没有觉得任何一个博主给品牌创造了好的回报。
就这个话说得很残酷，
但是事实就是这样。
与其这样，
我还不如就真的是找更加authentic的人。
就他真的很向往这个比赛，
这个机会对他来说非常珍贵。
我就把这样一个很珍贵的机会去给一个很真实这场比赛，
也很信任我们品牌的人，
剩下的宣传的部分，
物料的部分交给品牌我们俩做。
对，而且我做一个产品，
然后我肯定是希望他在备赛的时候，
甚至在参加UTMB之前参加其他比赛的时候，
就穿上我们的产品，
而不是说到了UTMB在临时换，
可能你在之前比赛的时候还穿着别的品牌的鞋。
啊，很多都是这样的。
然后我看到太多了，
就是他发的被赛铁都是另一个品牌的商单，
然后到了UTMB，
赛前一天还要再借一个商单，
然后比赛的时候再穿一个品牌。
品牌去记录一个运动员的，
或者一个我们的品牌好友，
他的一个被赛过程，
这个记录就不能是很流于表面的那种记录，
就是我光拍一点好看的画面啊，
用一点酷炫的运镜啊，
然后拍得美美的就行了，
我不是要这样的记录，
我是要正耳巴顶的记录，
他每天吃什么，
当地的环境是什么样的，
地形是什么样的，
饮食会造成什么样的影响吗？
他的身体状况有出现什么问题吗？
他是怎么解决这些问题的？
我觉得把这些东西记录下来，
会对其他的未来想要去参加类似这样的比赛的，
普通大众爱好者更有参考意义。
就这个视频它是真正有价值的，
不是一个只是为了展现一下这个品牌很酷很顺，
我觉得那个就没有必要，
所以我会把钱都放在这个地方，
摄影师也要在那边待着全程去拍，
找到愿意做这个活的摄影师吧。
这可能就是我现在能想到的，
我会做的一个方向，
我不会找明星跋山涉水去油体NB，
我真的没有必要。
你老是在给自己上难度，
这个活要干起来，
肯定是没有找明星这么容易的。
你把明星运到那边可不容易，
明星还得再扒个助理嘛。
你还得专门有公关的人员陪同，
去安排好他们的所有的行程和事务，
这可不轻松。
那毕竟是一次性的嘛，
你要长期跟拍那些草根运动员，
那你就是一个长时间的活。
嗯，长时间的项目。
对。
我就把它当成一个项目去做。
这个天璧我觉得它不是在这个时间点，
一个星期我让它有点声量就结束了，
我就想把它，
如果我真的要好好做，
我就想把它变成一个全年的事情，
全年可能都是围绕着这个时间点去发生的，
暂时是这样的想法吧，
我觉得大家也可以发表一下你们的看法，
就假设你是一个月炮品牌的品牌中间，
现在你要围绕由天璧去做一些营销策划，
你觉得还有什么可以做的？
哎，为什么这次没有品牌找Links去呢？
Links可能有别的工作吧。
我觉得它跑个ETC，
应该还是可以的吧。
对啊，绝对有问题啊。
有那种徒步攀岩的经验。
对啊。
而且它拍出来的东西我觉得品质应该是有保证的。
我是这样想的，
就是哪怕是我要找人去ETC组别，
我也不希望这个人只是体验一下，
就结束了，
他以后就远离月月炮了，
他就是来接这个商登，
就能不能这个人跑完一次之后，
他真的就暗上了月月炮，
我觉得这个故事才更加的Juicy。
就像Links,。
我不相信他跑完一次月月炮，
他之后会继续投入月月炮，
他没这个时间啊。
那我们基本上把就是花了大力气的品牌，
也都屡了一遍了。
那接下来我们讲讲第二期队的品牌吧。
第二期队的品牌其实就有两种情况，
第一种就是Global Mon Mon發力，
然后拿到了非常好的成绩，
也成为了这次的大赢家。
第二类就是我们中国团队猛猛发力，
但是Global其实没有什么东西，
就它不像前面讲到的就是松懈病境。
那我们先说说Global Mon Mon发力的这次的大赢家吧，
很多人都没有想到，
就是也是法国品牌Decanone。
Decanone这次他们的女子选手，
是拿到了一个天壁组别的冠军，
而且这个选手本身他也是非常的有话题度的，
因为他的本职工作是一个全职的副产科医生，
他的完赛成绩也是非常的优秀，
是突破了22小时的。
另外在TDS组别女子组的冠军，
Sara也是同样来自Decanone的选手。
还有他们有一位门店的店员杨伟灵，
他想说账号叫杨杨，
他还拿下了MCC组别的亚洲女子Decanone。
国内的选手是吗？
对，就MCC我们前面也讲过嘛，
他就是给赞助商、志愿者和当地居民提供的一个组别赛事。
Decanone国内的官方账号也是挺开心的吧，
小便应该也很开心，
第一时间就为几位选手都发了战报，
包括刚刚收到的那个门店店员，
他也拥有了自己的战报。
评论区就有好多人围过来，
追着小便要这些选手身上的所有的形头货。
对，我觉得这一点对Decanone来说是非常重要的。
其实Decanone今年在国内也推了一些越野跑写得快，
但之前都是找博主去测评嘛。
对。
但是我觉得对于越野跑来讲，
这个博主测评的说服力是明显不如经营分手穿着它站台的这个说服力。
对，而且越硬核的越相信站台的说服力。
对，因为其实Decanone之前在越野跑这个圈子里面，
可能上脚率没有那么高，
大家都不太敢去尝试它的产品。
但是这次由女子冠军的这个背书，
我相信大家应该更愿意去尝试Decanone写的。
对，关键就是和其他的品牌比起来，
Decanone确实还是价廉物美，
而且因为它是大品类嘛，
所以它是全身的装备，
它店里面都能买到，
就是帽子背包，
背包很多品牌是没有的嘛，
国内的店都买不到的，
然后Decanone都可以买到，
所以战报一发马上，
大家就在下面问货号，
甚至还有人在下面追问，
就是为什么其中某个选手的某个单品，
你没有写货号，
就认真到这个程度。
对，这个代货转化率应该是不错的。
是。
所以你把Decanone画到第二个层级里面，
是因为它没有花太多钱对吧，
从它官方这个态度来看还是比较重视的，
只是可能预算用的比较少。
我本来画到第二层级，
主要是因为它都是Global，
就是总部那边的体育营销在发力，
它在国内的品牌营销是没有什么大动作的，
我没有看到任何国内的选手或者博主。
是穿着Decanone赞助的产品，
他们也好像我知道他们没有组自己的那个，
战队,
我说的战队就是那个送装备的那个战队啊，
能看到的就是他们的小编发了几个战报，
对，就是没花太多钱对吧，
态度上是重视的，
总部态度是重视的，
但我估计按照这个趋势，
说不定明年他们本土团队。
可能也会有一些更大的动作吧，
那接下来可以说一说北面，
The North Face,。
The North Face就是感觉,。
嗯，你说它重视越远越跑吗，
但我其实又觉得它有一些资源其实都慢慢的在撤出，
比如说这一次其实，
我看到他们国内赞助的运动员只有王继签，
他参加的是UTNB阻别，
成绩好像是23小时多一点吧，
另外PTL阻别有一位叫行佬佬，
大家对他行佬佬行如凌，
我看他的型头应该是北面赞助的，
其他的就没有什么了，
就没有再看到有北面赞助的运动员了，
只看到一些他合作的博主，
总体来说不算是发力发的特别猛吧，
那和这两个品牌相对的其实有一个品牌，
我感觉它是反过来的，
就是它在Global那边，
我没有看到有太大的发力，
但是它在我们本土团队这里还是有发力的，
就是史苏鸟，
史苏鸟它是有找一些博主过去去体验他们的活动，
它在那边还和巴黎的一个跑步平台叫Distance，
联合发起了一个Strawlite的挑战，
就等于是把线上和线下联动起来了，
他们的签约运动员，
大家也都非常熟悉，
炎龙飞和橡浮招都去参加了，
但是很遗憾的是两位选手也都是退赛了。
另外,
史苏鸟他还赞助了一组PTL的团队，
成员也是非常有名的，
小太阳啊、怪兽、小麦，
他们自己也都是国内的一些赛事的运营者，
他们组了一个PTL的战队，
我看到他们身上的装备全部都是鸟的。
这个战队最后是有一名成员，
小麦退赛了，
另外的两个人完成了比赛。
所以史苏鸟是Global的团队没有什么太大的动作。
反正我没看到。
他们主要还是把精力放在国内的这些运营员身上。
那你刚才说北面他有Global的运动员吗？
有Global的运动员。
北面也在那边去做了落地的活动，
然后还有放音影片啊什么的。
那史苏鸟在越野跑上面投入会不会是？
国内的团队的决策。
中国公司的想法？
有这个可能性。
因为他其实这个品牌在国际上好像没有太多越野跑的记忆。
我看到好像说他的越野跑鞋也是一直有的，
但是事实上他的绝大多数的重心还是放在户外。
国内你知道的吗？
他还算是在安塔体系里的品牌。
对。
安塔体系里现在没有一个品牌不在做越野跑。
史苏鸟在做，可龙在做，安塔自己也在做。
就更多的可能是国内的一个决策吧。
对。
但是可以说是出事不利了，
因为就是两位人气非常高的运动员其实都没有完成比赛。
因为相互招考量本来的重点也不是在UKMB，
他可能更看重西部100。
哦，那为什么还要去参加呢？
也是为了一个曝光吗？
因为我听这个比赛又不能错过。
对，因为我听其他的博主说他好像在赛前就知道自己是没办法跑完，
甚至他的教练还建议他不要跑，
对，不要跑了，
但他还是坚持上了彩岛，
但跑了一段时候还是推赛了。
这个问题我觉得也是值得讨论的，
就是如果你的状态确实非常不理想，
作为一个职业运动员，
我们到底是要咬牙硬撑撑到完全不能再称为只还是理性放弃这个比赛。
嗯，这个你也不知道是不是赠助商的要求了。
哦，可能是这个原因。
当然这个只是我们的猜测，
不一定是这样的情况。
不得而知。
明知道自己的状态非常不理想，
甚至有伤病，
你还去上路哪怕只是跑了几十公里，
其实我觉得都是没有必要的加重了你的损伤啊，
不是吗？
还是这个情况从流向就开始了呀。
就我们中国人是苦耐劳的这个精神呢。
你这些是你顶着这个赞助商的压力，
你怎么也要在赞道上站一下。
嗯，如果是DNS的话，
可能也会怕舆论会不会有一些不好的评价吧。
对。
那其他还有一些小品牌，
像Norda Satisfied,。
其实也是在UtnB上积极营业的。
Norda他赞助的选手Rachel，
还是这次UtnB余自主的亚军，
也是给品牌张联了，
一个非常好的证字，
22小时15分。
那除了这些品牌，
还有一些像高池啊，
宋托啊，
Nightcore就是那个头灯的品牌，
Vibran呢,。
他们其实都在UtnB上，
其实是做了一些曝光，
做了一些动作的。
但是因为这些品牌，
他们的赞助选手，
其实跟我刚刚讲的这些运动，
协服的赞助选手，
基本上都是重合的，
所以我就觉得也没有必要再坠述了。
嗯。
哦，那我刚刚好像漏了一个品牌，
其实这个品牌在这次UtnB也没少花力气，
就是Goldwing,。
你知道这个品牌吗？
名字我听过，
但是我还真不知道它是做什么呢？
兼具了潮流属性的户外品牌吧。
哦。
这次我感觉它的策略就是赞。
呵呵。
所以它不是专注做月月炮的？
不是啊，
它而且是服饰为主，
我就看到是有很多的博主，
他其实本身在比赛的时候，
没有穿Goldwing，
他穿的就是其他的品牌的产品，
但是在比赛的前一天，
他会去帮Goldwing拍一套照片，
软直入一下他们的产品，
而且说的都还挺隐晦的，
就是他都没有说具体哪个单品，
他就是说穿了Goldwing的装备，
什么什么什么，
体验非常好之类的。
反正这个也能算赞助吗？
特地找了摄影师去拍的照片，
我觉得应该算是吧，
就是软性的一些支持。
哦。
就他没有穿Goldwing上赛场，
但是去了赛道。
对,
他是去了侠目尼，
在这个美好的环境下拍了一些美美的照片，
我觉得可能这就是品牌要的，
我就是要在这个很仰气的环境里，
拍些美美的照片给我们，
但是Goldwing他有一位自己赞助的选手，
是一个日本选手叫上田刘伟，
这个选手其实蛮有仁气的，
因为他的外情非常的优质，
在日本蛮有仁气，
在印刺上面很有仁气，
我有一次看一个不知道什么越野比赛的人家拍的视频嘛，
就是在不积点，
他在拍那个男子选手进不积点，
吃补给的那个状态，
他拍的是我们国内的选手，
我都不记得他拍的是谁了，
但是我的目光立刻就被旁边那个日本选手醒了，
因为那个人真的好帅啊，
我觉得好有型啊，
然后我后来去一查这个选手就是上田刘伟，
他在人群里你是无法不看到他的那种帅，
但是这个选手我没有查到他的完赛陈字，
甚至他有没有完赛我也不知道，
如果你翻墙上印刺应该是可以看到，
是的，或者我去查一查那个ETNB的网站，
我应该能找到，
但我也没有这个，
我倒也没有对他上头到这个程度，
还有一个品牌我觉得你好像漏掉了，
就是NORMAL,。
是的,
但这次KTW好像也没有参赛，
对,
他是在赛前宣布自己要退赛的吧，
都没有出现在赛道上DNS，
我自己觉得他应该早就想好不会参加了，
但这次NORMAL其实有一个新品，
就是他那个包，
好像还挺受欢迎的，
因为他有一些创新好像是做了一个模块化的设计，
就是你想加什么样的逐渐的那个包上你可以自己去选的，
对,
就可以扩大这个包的容量和他的装载功能，
对，我也看好几个去了UTMB的博主都在发这个包，
我觉得很快就会在其他的品牌看到这个包的复刻板了，
说起来，
在这次UTMB找资料的过程中我才意识到，
我们原来有这么这么多的越野跑媒体，
就小红树上不知道从什么时候开始就冒出了一大堆越野跑的媒体账号，
对,
这个也是很好理解的，
毕竟品牌都在头这个方面那肯定也会诞生媒体，
因为要赚品牌的钱啊，
真的就是在这两年甚至我可以说在这一年里就冒出来好多新的媒体账号，
那我刚刚其实一直没有说到一个也算是今年UTMB的大银家，
对,
很多博主都说它是今年最大的银家，
因为这次UTMB主别的冠军穿的就是他们的鞋，
那好像已经是连续两年了，
去年那个也是啊，
去年拿鞋子当酒杯喝酒的喝红牛，
也是穿的亚瑟士的鞋，
所以就是亚瑟士，
亚瑟士确实这两年真的好珍惜啊，
而且这次的冠军他的成绩也是非常的惊人，
是18小时16分29秒，
相当快的一个成绩，
另外OCC主别男女继军也全部都是亚瑟士的选手，
所以这次他在站台选手的品牌里存在感是非常强的，
好像说亚瑟士是所有主别前时总共60个名额里占比最多的，
他们Global这个体育营销太牛了，
你想这么多欧洲的品牌，
赞助的运动员其实没有亚瑟士赞助的这个成姿这么好，
这到底是鞋子太牛了还是他们体育营销太牛了，
我觉得主要是体育营销吧，
真的要给这个部门发肌腿了，
可以明显的感受到亚瑟士这两年真的很大力的在推越跑鞋，
不仅是国外国内也是，
在UtnB之前其实亚瑟士也合作了一些博主，
用备赛的这个概念去推荐他们的越跑鞋，
这个也算是一个取巧的方式吧，
因为可能人家都已经跟其他品牌谈好了，
我要穿他们的占比去比赛，
那我就跟你合作备赛，
这也是大家现在很通行的一种做法，
亚瑟士国内也有两位运动员是出战了，
一个是何富军一个是吴尔清，
两位也都是完赛的，
分别是OCC组别的33名和58名，
虽然说这个成绩不算是特别的耀眼，
但其实亚瑟士的官方账号也给两位选手都分别发了两篇图文，
去肯定选手的表现，
说实话我觉得这个也是品牌应该要为运动员做的，
不能说我家的运动员去比了这个比赛之后，
好像这件事情没有发生一样，
这个我待会就特别想说一个品牌，
必须要点名，
所以亚瑟士主要也是Globo在发的，
对是的，
所以我会把它放在第二档，
这一点我觉得跟有些品牌还是有区别的，
跟你刚才说的一些品牌，
他们主要在国内发的，
因为在Globo这个越野跑的热潮，
并没有像国内发展的这么快，
那亚瑟士为什么在全球范围内，
还要这么大手笔的去投资越野跑，
我觉得这个品牌它是有野心的，
因为它在Globo那块始终是干不过那几个阿迪，
基本上重大赛事的前进名，
都是被那些阿迪给刮分的，
亚瑟士作为曾经的跑鞋之王，
他肯定是不服气的，
那既然Globo我短时间内还赢不了你，
那我就在越野跑这块发的，
哦有道理啊，
他还是有这个心气的，
他开始布局越野跑，
我觉得可能比我们现在看到的这个成绩的出现要早得多，
对，那跟亚瑟士比较类似的就还有布鲁克斯，
同样也是一个在跑鞋领域深耕了很多年的，
对，这两个品牌的情况好像啊，
因为布鲁克斯也就是今年吧，
开始感觉他们的大作越野跑鞋，
对，都是推出了竞速的这个越野跑产品嘛，
那布鲁克斯主要也是靠Globo那边全球范围的法力，
他在CCC组别的男子组是有四个人进了前十，
然后在国内这块实际就没有太大的动作了，
他只是有一个签约的运动员拿下了Utnb组别的中国男子离散，
那总成绩可能就排名不是特别高了，
而且他也没有说找很多大博主啊，
或者是大的这个娱乐明星去参赛，
我看到好像有给一些博主装备，
但是感觉应该不是那种花了很多钱的合作，
就不是专属的这个战队嘛，
是因为他给装备的那些博主好像其他装备都不是布鲁克斯，
对对对，是，
估计也就是一些装备赞助，
对，所以算是做了一些东西，
但是不算特别的大动作，
对,
那我们也聊了很多在这次Utnb干大事的品牌，
也有一些中规中矩的品牌，
那与前面这些风风火火入局Utnb做品牌营销的品牌相比，
有两个品牌就还蛮灵类的，
因为他们那个中国市场部感觉就是完全自身失败，
甚至给我一种感觉是他们中国市场部是不是不知道Utnb这个赛事已经避完了，
那那不是三个吗？
我先说第一个阿迪达斯，
阿迪达斯现在在中国的团队，
我感觉他们对越野跑真的完全不在意，
完全不在意，
这也是特别另类的一件事情，
生意太好了，
看不上越野跑这三卦两草，
对,
他们而且是今年把Trail Running越野跑从原来的Terricks这条线布里出来了，
现在是放到了Running的这条线里面，
Terricks就是大家都知道他现在已经变成了山川礼嘛，
然后只做户外，
着重于做青徒步，
我觉得这个变化呢还算是合理的，
因为越野跑我觉得还是跟Running更相关一些吧，
你觉得合理吗？
你觉得不合理吗？
我觉得不合理啊，
人家其他什么都是把越野跑和户外变到一起啊，
你看Nike还是把越野跑从Running里面剥离出来，
专门跟户外做到一起做一个ACG的线，
他是故意要跟Nike反着来是吧？
因为我感觉阿迪现在是想把，
就阿迪中国吧，
他是想把Terricks彻底变成青户外，
城市户外的这个概念，
但是越野跑本身的，
你还是要跟这些严肃赛事有关系啊，
对不对，你不能完完全全只做休闲吧，
这有点奇怪吧，
他还是有竞技属性在的，
户外徒付这些东西，
他说白了没有什么竞技属性的，
所以他就是把有竞技属性的，
全部都变到Running这一去了，
我是觉得还蛮合理的，
还有是不是他们负责Terricks的同事，
就讨厌跑步，
不想碰跑步的东西，
所以直接把TerricksRunning丢出去，
这个布局我觉得可以理解，
另外一方面就是这次的UTMB，
阿迪达斯其实并不低调，
他们的global是有选手站台的，
但是你去看一看阿迪达斯在小红书的官方账号，
我记得只有一条在赛前关于产品的post，
其他的就没有任何的post，
他就包括他自己的选手站台，
中国的运动员完赛，
他都没有发笔记，
他连一个那个官号的笔记都懒得发，
其实这个是最简单的，
对，CCC组别这次女子的冠亚军，
都是阿迪达斯的选手，
而且穿的就是他们之前预热过的那双新的月鞋，
就大家也都很关注这双鞋子说实话，
然后你拿到了这样的成绩，
你至少一项不可思议要发个战报吧，对不对，没有，
另外就是国内阿迪达斯月月跑，
是有一名圈约选手叫陈琳，
他的网名叫哥哥琳，
其实他是一个挺有名气的选手，
这次在比赛的过程当中，
也是因为场位的严重不适，
其实一直都影响了他的发挥，
但是最后他还是坚持完赛，
而且取得了女子组第十四名的陈琳，
他保证是由天壁组别，
也是所有参加由天壁组别国内的女子选手的第一，
是一个很有韧性的姑娘吧，
就是在这样的困难之下，
他还是完赛了，
虽然说陈琳肯定是不如他原来的预期的，
就我了解他应该是阿迪达斯月月跑，
签约的仅存的运动员，
但是在阿迪达斯的官方账号上就没有为他发任何内容，
你别说这个了，
你拿关牙军他都没发，
他还会为国内选手单独发一篇吗？
对，就好像这件事情没有发生过一样，
就好像你去跑位不在乎，
这个东西我觉得不值得发在我们的笔记上，
这个态度我真的不理解，
就我不知道他们背后的考量是什么，
但是我觉得这个是说不过去的，
我觉得他们还是现在生意真的太好了，
对，一个是这方面，
另外一个是他把月月跑画到跑步那边去了，
那就没有一个人来专门看月月跑生意了吗？
老老不谈，爷爷不爱，
跑步的人，我肯定是先就是跑步那一块，
那个生意多大，那占比多大，
你月月跑才能给我带来多大的生意，
而且阿迪的月月跑生意在国内销量一直都一般嘛，
都变成了打折的主力了，
包括他最高端的那个大素流星，
甚至今年刚上的大素流星二，
也现在也打折打得很厉害，
那当然那个负责跑步人，
他更加不会把精力投入到这一块，
不管是产品还是市场营销还是销售，
重心都不在这一块，
他当然也不会去跟负责做光靠的人沟通，
去争取来给我发两遍笔记了。
我就可能真的是在这个时间点没人管这个事，
刚刚迁移过去，
谁来负责都还不知道的情况下，
就没有人来接这些事情。
好吧，这样说也可能是有他的原因，
但是我还是觉得如果我是这位选手，
我是会有点难过的，
明年肯定不牵你了。
真的吗？
我相信他如果开放出来的话，
应该是会有品牌，
一定会是想要签他的。
阿黎现在有两个重要的跑鞋在吹，
一个是Hyperboost,。
还有一个是营锋Pro，
他们中国线的产品，
跑步负责人手上有这么两个大项目，
他哪还有多余的精力投入到玉耶宝这一块？
营锋Pro还是Cloy的UTNB被赛战士，
被赛鞋。
别全数开玩笑了。
他发了一个就是商单嘛，
穿营锋Pro被赛UTNB，
不太约天币也就跑15公里。
你就算跑5公里一天，
你不能穿这个鞋去跑。
我觉得阿迪也是思路非常清奇的说实话，
大家都是被赛的，
然后我被赛我也是要给博主推越野跑鞋。
不是思路清醒，
这就是那个负责跑步人他的小算盘。
对吧，越野跑鞋又卖不出量，又不赚钱。
那我干脆就借这个机会来推我的路跑鞋嘛，
反正都是在我这一块货下面的，
都是由我来管的。
可能就是一个品牌的策略的倾向吧，
就是他现在就是放掉越野跑，
越野跑在他这里就是一个不太重要的部分。
路跑和三叶草已经帮阿迪达斯转的铜板拨满了。
他没有必要，
就是他没有那样的动力再去关注越野跑了。
对,
即便越野跑本身的这个运动的精神调性都在那儿，
但是对他来说这个东西真的不重要。
好，那另外一个在中国这边的品牌步，
我感觉也是完全不care越野跑的，
就是昂跑。
昂跑其实大家就是看一下那个站台的榜单，
他算是有所掌握的，
他的选手是获得了Utnb的亚军的好陈绩。
昂跑是有两位男子的选手跑进了Utnb的前十的，
男子前十。
然后TDS组别女子的第三也是昂跑的选手，
陈绩丹还是不错的，
但是在他们国内的官方账号上也是没有任何关于Utnb的品质的。
就好像这件事情没有发生过。
可能昂跑在国内确实没有太多越野跑的心智。
对，感觉也是不在意吧，
越野跑还没被昂跑放到他的calendar里面来。
他其实跟阿里也比较像，生意太好了，
牧跑和通勤都赚得盆满泼满。
对，他没有动力说我再要去找一个增长的赛道，
所以越野跑暂时可以放在那边不理会。
对，那为什么我说你忘掉了一个呢？
因为还有一个品牌，
大家可能也注意到了，
他是拿到了一个主别的冠军，
就是男子OCC主别的冠军，
而且他穿的是我今年推过的一双越野跑鞋，
这是迈勒的AP6，
Algility Peak,。
以前是叫蜂鸟，
但是他们现在不用这个中文名字，
直接用英文名字，
Algility Peak 6,。
这个英文没有几个人能念得清楚啊，
蜂鸟这个名字不是挺好的吗？
对，我不知道他们为什么不用了，
而且这个还不是一双竞速的越野跑鞋，
它更像是一双给出跑者，
就是刚入门的越野跑者准备的鞋。
但是迈勒签约的这位选手，
就是穿着他拿到了OCC的冠军，
这个真的也是非常不容易的。
哇，那感觉迈勒今年也是在越野跑上发力了，
对啊，你想多少大品牌，
像拿一个主别的冠军都没拿到呢，
结果迈勒拿到了。
那迈勒的关号还是有给他发了一个战报的，
你看迈勒都知道要给自己的站台选手发一个战报，
但是迈勒我觉得跟其他两个牌材不一样，
不是不想做，
他就没钱做，
他可能是想做，
毕竟现在体量太小，
而且他现在是归特不管嘛，
所以自己可能说了也不算，
也是,
想做也拿不到这个预算，
体量太小了，主要是。
所以这三个品牌确实是有点，
怎么说啊，
说了严重一点，
就要爆天天雾了，
浪费了这样的好故事，
对啊,
你有站台的选手，
但是没有把它利用好，
就在这个时间点上，
让我觉得他们不太有体育精神，
这么严重吗？
对啊,
这是一个很重要的赛事，
在越野跑的世界里面，
它是一个有象征意义的赛事，
我说的稍微夸张一点啊，
就在这样的赛事上，
我们的运动员拿到了成绩，
小红说一篇笔记不值得你发一下吗？
就只能代表它完全不在意这个事情，
对,
那我就说它没有运动精神了，
就只能说这个品牌里面，
负责这块的人它不在意，
那就这个人没有运动精神，
不过你这么说也是有一点道理的，
难道这个品牌里面，
就没有一个人在关注越野跑吗？
好歹我看到这个消息，
我去跟负责的人打个招呼，
然后去跟关浩的运营，
沟通了一下，
你帮我发一个帖子，
发一个内容，
这个又不难，
而且也不花什么钱，
那公司太大了，
架构太复杂了，
如果这不是你部门负责的事情，
你这样有点渐运，
我感觉你给人家找事呢，
也不太好，
对,
其实还有一个比较特殊的品牌，
也就是Mount to Coast,。
那这其实是一个国内的品牌，
但是它的主要的生意放在国外，
你这个定义呀，
我就证明一下，
他们自己创始的说法，
就是我们不定义自己是个中国品牌，
还是一个国外品牌，
就我们是一个有全球观的品牌，
但它的创始人是中国人，
对,
创始的地方也是在国内呀，
Mount to Coast这个牌子,。
它的注册幣在香港，
它的研发，
它的生产都是在广东，
它怎么能不算是一个国内品牌呢，
就是一个国内品牌，
但是它是现在国外开始受卖，
这只能说是它品牌的一个生意的策略，
那你不能说你就不算是国内品牌的嘛，
即便是到2026年，
其实国内消费者，
这个崇洋媚外的这种购物倾向，
还是没有能够完全消除，
你从它的身上就可以看出来，
它如果是一个土生土长的国内品牌，
然后它把生意放在国内的话，
它这个价格我觉得是不太会有人这么去追捧，
甚至可能会有很多人去骂它，
跟它类似的像大年，
像Rancy Fly,。
甚至包括那道清宫，
你价格稍微卖贵一点，
都会被人骂，
但是Mount to Coast的这么贵的价格，
现在很多人反而要想尽各种办法去买，
跑到香港去找代购，
把它买回来，
即便你是一个国内品牌，
但是你的生意重点是在国外，
大家依然会觉得你这个品牌身上会有一些光环，
依然愿意为了你付出更高的价格。
不过可不敢说真话，
我觉得多少还是能看出一点这个倾向呢？
它会去投入做很多专业的体育营销，
它的产品定位又非常的巧妙，
就它直接是打那个超马超长距离越野这样的一个定位，
就让你感觉比较容易认可它这个品牌的高端性帮，
你让我想想，
如果大年上来就是打超马品牌的调性，
品牌的Image做的非常的高端，
然后一双鞋卖一千八，
你让我想想，
我觉得也不耐性，
当然你说的这些肯定是它成功的很重要的因素，
就是有一个完整的品牌形象，
而且它有一个比较完整的产品规划，
这点确实相对于其他的初衷品牌也是要强一些的，
这个就惯例到我们上一期说的那个产品经理的职责的问题，
然后还有一个比较清晰的品牌定位，
这些确实都很重要，
但是不管怎么说，
如果你是一开始把你的销售许到把你的生意重点放在国内的话，
你这个价格我觉得真的是很难做得起来。
所以还是要在国外先做一些背书，
然后让国内的一些喜欢小众品牌的追逐新品牌的一些装备档，
能够迫不及待想要去买它，
慢慢的形成一个国内的口碑，
所以Mount Coast这次在UTMB也还算是拿到了不错的成绩，
TDS组别的冠军和MCC组别的女子冠军都是Mount Coast的选手，
那我觉得对于一个出创的小品牌而言，
你能够拿到这样的成绩非常不错了，
我觉得像Mount Coast这个体量，
你让它花钱找博主啊什么的去穿他们的装备袍好像也不是很现实吧，
最多就是一些产品的setting啊，
然后看看博主愿不愿意去参加一下他们的活动，
分享一下他们的新产品之类的，
就只能做到这个程度了，
我们也看到一些比较有话题度的事件了，
就你知不知道这一次有一些没有UTMB名额的跑者，
为了去蹭一些品牌的战队装备，
然后他就自己批了一张UTMB的参赛的那个，
还有什么事啊？
参赛的那个邮件吧是截图啊，
然后就拿到了一些品牌的赞助装备，
他又拿其他选手参加UTMB的照片，
把自己的人批到人家的那个背景上面去，
然后拿着这个照片去互动品牌，
这都可以吗？这不会被查出来吗？
就现在就是被网友查出来的呀，
因为网友发现这个女生她的完赛成绩，
跟她的一个男性朋友的完赛成绩是一模一样的，
其实这个男生跑了UTMB的里面的比赛，
女生没有拿到名额，
但是女生就是用了她的照片，
撇死了，然后拿了她的成绩，
把名字批承了自己的，
就交给了品牌。
那品牌做了赞助的时候也不会去调查一下吗？
品牌就是看截图嘛，
然后你给她截图就可以了呀，
她还要调查什么？
这个参赛名单应该是都能查到的吧，
官网上的那不会公开吗？
你就去稍微查一下就知道在做假呀。
有没有一种可能，
就是说品牌也只是想说，
你想用树上给我发了，
有了图有了数据就可以了，
我管你是不是真的出现了？
可以没有认真去做调查。
你真的去参加和你没去参加，
谁知道，
如果不是有热心网友，
真的是去扒了出来，谁知道呀。
我反正该拿的照片我拿到了，
我该拿的数据我也拿到了。
这波助也是有点离谱了，
你去准备只找一次性的赞助是吧，
以后都走不了这条赛道。
其实我觉得有可能在此之前，
她已经用这样的资料互动过很多次品牌了，
只是之前品牌没有发现，
但这次因为Utm比本身能去跑的人就不多，
要怎么偏偏这么巧，
你们四个人都去跑了，
然后成绩还一样，
就有热心网友，
据说这一次他们这个小团体一共有四个人，
只有一个人跑了，
三个人都是假的，
据说是这样，
如果我这个信息不准确大家可以纠正我，
这个事情太不合理了嘛，
所以才导致有热心网友去扒了一下他们的成绩，
才发现了这件事情，
如果不是这样的话，
其实也就互动过去了，
这个月大头品牌我也要点名一下，
就是猛马巷，
不知道为什么猛马巷也来捉月野跑，
又户外在中国都还没搞明白呢，
中国关了这么多店，
现在又去搞月野跑，
又被博主这样耗了羊毛，
猛马巷现在是谁的，
那可能内部负责的人他也没有真的用心去验证，
他自己可能对Utm比也没有那么了解，
所以才会让博主钻到这个孔子，
我是觉得品牌可能也要再自我反显一下，
就是大家所谓的组战队送装备这个做法，
是不是还要继续用下去，
或者说是不是大大小小的比赛，
不管是路跑比赛、马拉松比赛、月野比赛，
我们都要用这样的方式去增加品牌的曝光，
你在这忽悠也没用，
反正只有哪个品牌真的做出来一些不一样的东西，
然后取得了很不错的反馈，
不管是这个声量的反馈，
还是生意转化的反馈，
我觉得其他的品牌才会跟进，
就举个例子，我觉得最有可能的还是Nike吧，
就是他做了一个长线的项目，
就比如说你刚才说我去找一些草根的越跑运动员，
然后让他们从备赛开始就一直穿过的产品，
我再去给他拍一些质量非常高，非常有传播度的素材，
最后他占上了UTMB的赛场，
然后他在赛场上取得了自己满意的不错的成绩，
整个项目收获了一个比较好的效果，
只有出现这样的情况我觉得才会有其他的品牌跟进，
才会慢慢放弃这种短期的合作方式，
就还是要有一个成功案例让大家调转枪头，
否则你只要大家自发地去改变，这个不太现实啊。
我为什么说就是这个方式真的不是说每个比赛都适用，
因为我觉得每个比赛的特点是不一样的，
它的本身的热度和它的聚焦人群是不一样的，
比如说有一些在国内的人气比较高的马拉松赛事，
大家真的很爱组战队送装备，
这个我觉得某种程度上我可以理解的，
因为本身它就是个本土赛事，
大家抬头不见，低头见，你网上看不到，
你比赛的时候也能看到，对不对，
哎，那么多人穿了阿迪的鞋，
那么多人穿了B麦的鞋，
那至少我参加比赛的这几万号人我都能看得到，
这也算是一个线下的露出，
会让大家产生一种感觉就是，
哇，这个鞋最近好多人穿啊，
这也是有用的，
但是于UTMB这个比赛，
你就派那么几个博主去在那边穿着装备露出一下，
发个笔记，
首先在当地它也产生不了什么影响力，
其次我看了一下所有的这些拿到装备发笔记的博主，
数据也非常的一般，
然后在笔记里面它是拼盘嘛，
通常一个人都耗了几家的羊毛，
所以它一篇笔记里面要拼几个拼盘的装备，
我也没有觉得有任何一个装备它能介绍得很清楚，
有任何一个装备能拖影而出，
那不管从质量还是从你要的数据上，
我觉得这个都是没有什么太大的回报的一件事情，
而且这一次我看到有热心网友收集了一下，
Utnb组战队送装备的品牌多达24个，
就它能收集到的就有24个，
可能还不值，
我们来报一下这些品牌好不好，
报菜名，
对，我来报菜名，
凯勒什福格，
萨洛蒙，
蒙马相，
北面安踏冠军，
仗义,
叻琪,
二普一度，
Craft,
Yotu,
3M,
它还有运动相关的产品吗？
SN,
STORE,
361度,
猛士,
麦乐,
宋托,
麦圣,
伯尼斯眼镜，
等等,
居然没有户外特工，
对,
我还特地去看了没有户外特工，
感觉上好像大家都觉得Utnb是个大事，
我们怎么样都得蹭点露出，
蹭点露出好过没有露出，
所以大家用的最平易敬人的方式，
成本最低的方式就是送装备，
对,
话说我来送装备确实也花不了我几个钱，
但我确实也觉得这个事本身对品牌没有什么太大的意义，
还有你这个里边安踏冠军也只是送一些产品吗？
他好像是有几个运动员的，
有三位女性的运动员去参加了比赛，
但是成绩不是特别的理想吧，
我看到了更多的安踏冠军的露出，
还真的都是那些他赞助的装备的选手发的内容。
安踏冠军这次在Utnb好像还发布了新产品吗？
就是他的猎损事？
对,
他们也在侠目尼斯有做一个自己的展区的，
安踏冠军的品牌总监和产品总监吧？
都去来吗？
对，都去来，
不是品牌总监，是品牌负责人。
品牌负责人和产品总监都去了侠目尼斯，
然后还上了刨折日历的采访，
我记得，
但因为主要是他们的运动员的层次没有很亮面，
所以我可能前面收集信息的时候就没办法放进去。
其实前面讲了这么多品牌，
他们这次在Utnb的营销，
我还是回到我最开头想聊的那个话题嘛。
大家这次在Utnb的投入，
拿到自己理想中的回报了吗？
按照我的观察和我去收集的数据来说，
我觉得可能这一次很多品牌是会有一些失望的，
甚至我觉得小红书平台可能也会有一点失望。
我们前面讲到的侠目尼的日雨夜，
是这次小红书给Utnb专门设置的一个话题嘛。
所以这次发布Utnb相关内容的网友，
其实大家都会加上这个话题，
但是我看了一下这个话题，
他现在的话题浏览量只有152万，
讨论次数不到1万次。
我给一个Antmarc，就是Herox。
Herox小红书也给了他一个专门的话题，
当然这个有点不公平啊，
因为他已经有好多好多场了嘛。
Herox这个相关话题，
他的三个话题的浏览量是2亿，
他的讨论度是93.5万。
哇，差了100倍。
那我就算是Herox已经比Utnb多了很多场，
也不至于多到100场。
对，其实我觉得这个话题很难把它关联到Utnb啊，
特别是对于那些不是那么了解Utnb的人，
可能根本都不知道你说这个夏末尼的日语也在指什么东西。
你只要是一个就是有越野跑或者户外标签的用户，
你不可能不知道，
因为他天天在给你发这个世界偏爱野路子的专题，
就他每周至少要告诉你两次吧，
我们现在有这样一个话题，
你加这个话题你会有流量，
所以世界偏爱野路子这个话题从8月4号到8月31号，
差不多一个月的时间吧，
这个大的话题他获得的流量量也只有1667万次，
讨论度是13.4万，
也就是说所有带了这个标签的人可能都在用这个话题发内容，
但是他的数据我个人觉得是匹配不上是红书给予的这个流量加持的。
这就说明两个问题，
第一个就是越野跑要出圈还是比Herox难度更高，
特别是Utnb，
就像我们在开头说的，
如果平时不关注这个人，
可能根本就不知道Utnb或者里边这几个组别到底是什么意思，
那另外一点可能就说明越野跑的人群比Herox的人群还是要少一些，
你说人群总数吗？
参与的人群总数吗？
对，参与和关注的加到一起，
参与的不一定少，
但是关注的少很多，
对，因为毕竟全国一年就有这么多场越野跑赛事，
我觉得你说参与的人数会比Herox少吗？
不一定，因为Herox很多人都在重复参加，
但是最起码我们在社交媒体上看到大家的讨论度和关注度而言，
我有一种感觉就是越野跑并没有大家以为的这么热，
对，而且即便很多讨论的人他是在骂Herox，
那也说明骂Herox的人也比骂越野跑的人要多很多，
因为你在骂他也是在给他增加流量，
增加关注度。
往往热铁都是骂出来的，
越野跑前一生最热的话题就是那个下坡嘛，
那个也是没骂出来的，
就是有一个人说他花了好像八万块钱去学，
对，我不知道八万八千啊，八万是不是有点离谱啊，
去学那个越野跑下坡技术，
然后就有人说我的农村长大的从小就会下坡上坡什么的，
就有很多博主在玩这个感冒，
越野跑非常火火到所有的品牌都在入局越野跑，
这个现象我觉得是不是一种品牌媒体和自媒体人三方打造的一个幻想，
还有咨询机构，
对我真心的发出这个灵魂考问，
就是他真的像我们以为的这么火吗，
因为我们真的是活在了信息检访里，
虽然我们天天都在刷到越野跑的信息，
但是这个是小红书给我们制造的检访，
所以我觉得唯有数据可以告诉我们这个东西是不是我们以为的这么火，
那根据我现在的看到的数据来说我并不这么觉得，
那另外一方面我看销量嘛，
那如果说这些品牌他们的越野线的产品都蒙涨，
或者是说做越野跑的品牌他的生意蒙涨，
那是不是就代表这个越野跑他也火了，
你觉得呢，
就如果说塞洛蒙他现在生意飞起，
能代表越野跑这个市场非常火热吗？
我觉得至少从阿迪身上看不出这个倾向，
你说阿迪他有越野跑的产品嘛，也有啊，
他的产品你也不能说他不强对吧，
他一个Tarox的越野跑鞋有这么多的鞋款，
为各种不同类型的越野跑者都准备了鞋款，
而且他的性能虽然说有些人觉得他的门槛比较高吧，
但是他在这些重大赛事里边也是有站台有冠军备出的，
还有一个就是设计阿迪的那些越野跑鞋你也不能说他很难看，
不难看啊，
对啊,
但是他就是能轮到今天这样的一个，
哎,
那你想说阿迪才是最清醒的那个人是不是，
我早就看透了越野跑，
并没有那么活热，
我就不追这个，
不忙碌的往里头浅，
哇,
突然发现原来最清醒的是阿迪，
但这跟女孩说的不矛盾啊，
你小时候发两条这个战报，
这也不需要头浅啊，
投入点关注也行，
投入点尊重就可以了，
就我在想说越野跑品牌生意好或者是越野跑鞋卖的好，
他是不是等同于越野跑这个运动和越野跑的散事他祸了？
散事怎么说呢？
反正从大的机构的统计数据来讲，
散事肯定是在增加的，
散事的规模，
散事的数量，
包括我散事的收入都是在增加，
但是这又要举一个反例，
我要说到异常了，
异常前几年每年都还有好几场越野菜，
这两年异常都没有，
而且几年年初说要重新举办的这个3168到现在也没有疑讯了，
我觉得八成一年也是举办不了了，
反正从异常我是看不出这个越野跑有越来越活着的一个趋势，
那我也去刨更问题了一下，
就是因为我觉得在大家都说不清楚的情况下，
我们还是拿数据说话，
刨更问题了一下越野跑火了，
这个事是怎么传出来的，
然后我发现有很多数据都是来自一个叫爱梅咨询发布的。
2025年中国运动户外市场消费行为调查数据，
这个算是白皮书一样的东西吧，
然后在这个东西里面他特别重点的提到说越野跑的这个市场，
我们从赛事的数量上看，
截止到2026年5月1日，
全国大大小小的越野跑赛事累计局办了400多场，
同比增加31%，
参赛规模达到了103.8万人次，
从这个数据上看好像你会觉得那比赛是多了呀，对吧，
但是我又去看了一下所有的比赛的名戏，
我就是一个一个看他到底是什么比赛，
其实在所有被列到的这些比赛里面，
我发现将近有30%左右的比赛，
其实都是由品牌主办的赛事或者是品牌的训练赛，
他的名字就是比如说像什么可龙某某某某山训练赛这样的比赛，
他都是统计到这400多场比赛里的，
在看这个比赛本身的热度的时候，
我们要把这些品牌投进去的东西先把它剥离掉嘛，
因为品牌是跟随着这个所谓的热潮，
他去加注了这样的小赛事和训练赛。
这个就跟那个英伟达投的那些AI公司一样，
左脚踩右脚，螺旋上天。
对，对，这个我觉得大家一定要冷静下来看，
另外还有一个数据，我觉得也是我会比较警惕的，
就是我的脑子里面这根线就已经攻紧了，
巨该咨询机构称啊，
就是在他的这个调查数据里面显示，
2026年全国的越赛市产业整体市场规模会达到648亿，
他预计到2030年会突破1579亿元，
我就把这个数字放在这里，
2030年我会回来再看有没有达到这个数字。
这个复合年资党率是高达24.94%，
好后面重点来了，
他说赛时运营的直接收入今年有望突破67亿元，
同比增幅达到67.4%，
看到这个数字大家肯定都兴奋了对吧，
但是我后来又去找了一下，
就目前2026年过半这个时间点而言，
其实国内绝大多数的越野赛事公司并没有盈利，
大家是亏着钱在做赛事的，
就是因为大家也都相信越野跑能活下去，
现在是怎么样一个运营的模式，
就是说如果我这家赛事公司有一个比赛他还能赚钱，
我用这个比赛赚来的钱去贴补其他三个亏钱的赛事，
我慢慢地把那三个赛事再养起来，
但是这三个赛事他能不能养起来，
这个现在就不知道了。
我怎么感觉越野跑赛事以后要上保避节的情况。
大家光看那几个大数字，
你把那大数字放在PPT上，
老板确实看得心潮澎湃，
但是你再往下申巴一下，
我觉得这个局面并没有大家想象的这么好，
而且现在的赛事的报名的热度其实也是寡头效应嘛，
就是大的那几个有名的赛事一票难抽确实，
报名都要靠巧，
但是你要知道大部分的中小赛事，
它其实都面临一个报名报不满的局面，
我们可能作为，
我不要脸地说一句啊，
就是小红树上的博主会有很多品牌，
可能来问我们比不比赛啊什么的，
你如果是这样的人，
你是看不到那些小比赛的，
他不会在小红树上有很大的声量的，
你甚至都不知道有这样的比赛，
他的比赛可能连报名都报不满，
但是这些东西他不会在小红树上出现，
所以小红树上所有的越野跑者，
越野跑博主，
大家都觉得我们的春天来了，
越野跑要活起来了，
越野跑是停火，
现在是比以前好很多了，
但是我觉得他没有大家想象中的这么好，
这是我通过这几天疯狂的收集相关的信息，
我自己都出了一个结论，
对,
我觉得越野跑的基本盘还是比较稳的，
就是越野跑的死忠粉，
或者越野跑的这些核心的参与者，
他应该是不会随着这个市场的热度突然增加，
或者是突然减少，
他们一直在那，
只是因为这两年这个市场特别活，
所以突然可能涌进来一些，
包括我自己都是，
你说呢我今天都借了多少越野跑协的这个合作了，
甚至都要快赶上路跑协的数量了，
你这么说，
给人感觉你上当有多多营养，
其实也没多少，
对,
因为路跑协也没几个，
因为路跑协更少，
等等今年确实是这样，
对,
那这种情况肯定是不正常的，
还有一个就是我们刚刚也讲到的，
今年越野跑之所以大家都觉得热，
也是平台在推播出来，
因为小红叔他不亦娱历地在给越野跑加热，
我们大家再回应一下，
小红叔曾经加热过哪些运动，
滑雪啦，飞盘啦，骑行啊，
攀岩呢，
皮克球，
皮克球啊，对，
小红叔确实有这个能力，
就是他想让谁火谁就能火，
可能是这样啊，
现在轮到越野跑了，
我觉得真的不能太乐观，
也有很多人说越野跑不是飞盘，
不是骑行不是滑雪，
越野跑跟他们不一样，
我想追问一下，
哪里不一样，
就还是我刚才说了嘛，
因为越野跑它的基本盘是稳的呀，
滑雪也有基本盘，
飞盘也有基本盘，
骑行也有基本盘，
飞盘的基本盘这个体量跟越野跑，
骑行也有基本盘嘛，
基本盘撑不起这么多的车行，
撑不起这些品牌在中国开店，
对这个肯定是，
对,
滑雪一直有基本盘，
北方人一直有滑雪的习惯呢，
但是滑雪曾经真的非常非常火过，
它的季节性太强了，
越野跑也有季节性，
你刚刚还说我们现在夏天。
并不适合进山跑，
在我们这块不适合，
但是在北方是适合的呀，
高海拔地区也是适合的，
那高海拔地区你又限制了人数呀，
对,
而且你说装备，滑雪，越野跑，骑行，
都是重装备的运动，
那你说玩飞盘的人都是为了社交，
他们不是真正在玩，
那我觉得很多人去越野跑也是为了社交，
并没有那么多人很享受孤独的在山里跑，
对吧,
大家还是成群绝对的，
周末去跑个山比较开心嘛，
对,
这个没有人能给出答案，
但是作为平台作为咨询机构，
他肯定要给出一个这个幻想嘛，
所以我就说马上就是紫方营造出来的一个幻想，
对,
就是他要给大家一个希望，
让大家奔着这个希望去努力，
他万一成了挺好，
他万一没成，
那明年可能这个咨询机构。
再回给大家一个新的方向，
让大家再朝着这个方向去跑，
所以回到这个UtmB吧，
感觉话题有点特有了，
我觉得品牌如果要在UtmB上面投入，
首先自己还是要有过硬的产品，
不管到什么时候，
不管这个约跑是热，
还是以后没有那么热了，
你只要有过硬的产品，
这个市场里始终会有你的一块蛋糕，
其次呢？
其次还是要保持一分冷静嘛，
就是我们开头说的，
不要把鸡蛋全都放在一个篮子里边，
你在这块投入过大，
万一过了年约跑没有那么火了，
那你这个投入就打水漂了，
比如说我们现在看到很多自行车店，
都是慢慢的在关店的，
这肯定不是我们希望看到越野跑这块出现的。
不过如果说我们越野跑的这些赛事，
能够很健康的运营下去的话，
就像你说的，
它基本牌应该还是在那里的，
但我觉得真的品牌还是要稍微冷静一下。
还有一点就是在签运动员这个上面，
包括很多其他的博弈也提到，
就是国内很多越野运动员的身价，
越来越高，
确实是有些虚高，
但你在这个时候如果跟他签了一个长约，
那可能对你后面这个品牌的策略，
就会构成一定的束缚。
这对品牌来说很矛盾，
因为你不签长约，
万一他这几年表现非常好，
对，因为现在大家都在划大家先强烈，
对，你后面可能会被对手用更高的价格把他签走。
对。
总之我觉得现在的这个看起来很繁荣的景象，
里面还是有很多地方，
品牌也好运动员也好，
大家都可以再去总结一些经验，
然后再梳理一下自己未来要怎么走吧，
就不要一头热的就往里冲冲冲，
这个可能就得不到大家想要的一个比较好的结果。
对。
那我问你个问题啊，
如果说明年有田笔有品牌让你去，
不管是跑也好，
还是去做一个记录者，
做一个观察者也好，
去报道这个比赛也好，
你愿意去吗？
不承担签略，
签略你要自己承担。
那品牌给我提过什么东西？
提过一个机会啊。
他不承担签略我自己也可以去啊，
干嘛要品牌给我提就。
那我换一下，
品牌只承担你的签略，
但是没有任何其他的费用，
你愿意去吗？
可以啊，
这个没问题啊。
你去干嘛？
你能干嘛？
我做为一个观察者，
我就算看跑鞋我也能出点东西吧，
如果他让我跑的话，
我跑个MCC或者ETC也行吗？
那如果品牌只承担一半的签略，
你要自己承担一半的签略，
哪有这种合作？
有的有的，
你愿意去吗？
那你承担签略，
呃,
也可以考虑吧，
毕竟瞎不离，
我也没去过。
啊，是去旅游的什么，
品牌赞助你去旅游的。
我当然也是要给品牌出内容的。
那你快问我。
那你呢？
我斗争了很久，
我一开始写在这里的答案是我不去，
因为我觉得我去就是浪费了这个名额，
因为我真的没有那么了解越野炮，
我也没有那么热爱越野炮，
我觉得像这么重要的机会，
还是要留给那些更纯粹的越野炮的爱好者，
或者就是留给更有影响力的人。
那我觉得我两边都不斩，
我觉得浪费了品牌的这个机会。
你不觉得自己能排除有影响力的内容吗？
我不觉得。
你现在都这点信心都没有了。
啊，你去看这次于天璧，
就是他的短视频，
我觉得自媒体人和媒体还是有差别的，
自媒体人这个就别杠了，
就是媒体真的是专业的，
人家的团队抓这种赛道的物料素材，
那真的是很专业的，
就是你看到的大部分好的内容，
全都是媒体产出的。
那我一个自媒体，
我一个个人，
我到那边我凭什么能够拍出好的东西？
不可能啊。
而且他不是那种封闭场地，
他是开放式场地，
就是你跟所有的选手，
你最多就是见一面，
他就跑掉了。
那我怎么去拍摄好的内容？
我觉得这不太现实。
你可以拍跑的慢人，
你自己不关这个人。
嗯,
就我觉得我没有这个能力，
我拍不好，
我没有办法给品牌一个很好的东西，
而且品牌就有趣呢，
我肯定要给品牌产出啊。
品牌只需要你拍出有传播力的，
他没有规定你一定要拍什么东西吗？
那我觉得你作为一个自媒体人，
你还是得有这个自信啊，
否则你都还没有去尝试，
你就觉得自己拍不出来，
那还干什么自媒体，
你也不用拍。
我可以去做更适合我的事情啊，
就这个事情我觉得没有那么匹配吧，
就我不配。
但是我后来又想了想，
我昨天晚上没事干的时候，
我又想了想，
就既然这个品牌，
他死几百年要找我，
先被他死几百年要找你。
一定是看到了我身上有什么特别的地方，
那我也可以给他这个机会。
你这个话说，
他说更没人找你了。
反正也没人找，
我就随便说说，
就努力看看能做一些什么不一样的东西吧，
就算做不出也算是一次尝试吧。
对啊，你肯定要去尝试。
你不是不行，
说得好像就有品牌来找我，
没有。
就我觉得这个事要不找我，
我觉得天经地义也就这么说吧，
就没有任何的心理不平衡，
或者羡慕别人，
我觉得应该的。
虽然说很多人讲说Utnb，
现在越来越商业化呀，
但它毕竟还是一个非常重要的越野赛事。
在这个赛道上，
也总是会给我们留下一些非常动人的故事。
就比如我们会看到70多岁的老人，
他依然会去参加Utnb这个赛事。
我也希望我能一直运动到这么老的时候，
我希望我自己这么老的时候，
我还可以运动，
我还能够很开心的去跑进山野，
我也希望我自己是这样的。
还有就是这一次，
有一名下之贪玩的选手，
他是由他的42位团队成员。
辅助他在轮椅上去完成了这个Utnb祖别的赛事。
对，这个我也看到了。
不是那个团队帮着他把轮椅抬上山，抬下山。
这个在我看来也是一个没有办法想象的事情。
但他们就说，
我们即便是这么艰难的去和他一起完成比赛，
我们也不想放弃他，
我们希望能够盖着Johnson一起去看Utnb赛道上的风景。
这个团队在2024年和2025年都分别参加了。
Utnb的OCC祖别和CCC祖别，
然后每一次都是完赛的。
它没有关门。
对，每一次他们可能这个团队都需要更多的人来加入，
来轮流去辅助排这个轮椅。
所以这次这个团队就达到了42个人。
这个祖别也是Utnb开放给大家的。
就是如果你是特殊选手的话，
你也是可以来参加这个比赛的。
我觉得这也是这个比赛特别有魅力的地方吧。
它可以让我们看到这么动人的故事。
就是让我们相信说，
不管生活给了你什么样的致命一击，
只要你愿意，你还是可以去看这么美的风景。
就时候我就知道有些人会说什么，
哎，你要有钱呀，你要有时间呀。
但我觉得在有钱有时间之前，
首先是你有这样的生命力和你有这样的意愿。
所以我想这些同样也是Utnb留给我们的非常美好的回忆吧。
可能Utnb今天的成功离不开它的商业化，
也离不开这么多基因运动员为我们书写的这些很规律的传奇故事。
但是我觉得它的成功并不仅仅是因为这些。
好吧，那我们今天聊了这么多，
也是我们俩作为旁观者对今年Utnb的一些印象。
当然主要是对品牌在Utnb的一些营销方面的印象。
对。
还是之前说过很多次的那个老话，
就是我们对越野赛这个热度有这么多的意见，
并不是说我们不希望这个运动越来越好，
毕竟我们自己也是受益者，
但是也是希望品牌能够更加理性一些，
能够让这个热度延续的更长一些。
因为品牌一定要从这些投入里边收到一个合理的回报，
才能够继续去投入。
还是那句话，
就是你是因为它热了，
我们才要去做它，
还是因为大家真的看到了越野跑的魅力，
看到了越野跑赛事的魅力，
所以我们要去靠近它。
你现在要有一个高了，
这个品牌只要能从越野跑里边赚到钱就可以了，
不能指望品牌能看到越野跑的。
那如果是这样的话，
我可以肯定越野跑活不了太久。
是吗?
对,
因为大家都不傻，
大家这一波热潮知道你越野跑鞋又变成了一个潮流，
我这两年会买它，
过两年新的潮流出来了，
我就会去买新的潮流了。
你真正能留下的只有那些因为大家的宣传，
因为大家一起的推动，
而爱上越野跑的那些人，
那些人才会为你留下来。
所以如果各大品牌都没有看到这一点，
只是想说我们先卖产品，
我们先把产品的曝光度做起来，
我觉得这是不幸的。
那我就可以把话放在这儿，
就活不了太久。
当然我们不希望这种情况发生，
我是不希望今年能接到越野跑鞋的合作，
明年接不到了。
可能是因为我们这次节目做完，
不要说明年了，
现在开始就接不到了，
会不会有这个情况？
希望各大品牌的负责人都不要来听这期节目。
我自己觉得还是挺开心的，
就是这一次借着这个Utmb的话题，
好好地去了解了一下这个赛事，
还有很多的越野跑运动员，
他们的一些背景和故事，
也让我觉得非常的上头，
最近好像又自己注入了一些精神弹奔的感觉。
是吗?
那你的弹奔是，
让你有什么样的动力呢？
是让你想去跑越野跑吗？
还是让你想更多地关注越野跑？
让我会更关注越野跑，
而且我会更有动力去爆下一场越野跑的比赛，
因为你看我已经很久没有爆任何赛事了。
那你不是刚收伤了吗？
就不影响了，小伤。
跑了个小伤，
因为这也是被精神弹奔影响，
这个很不好。
就那天我去跑山的时候，
我就满脑子都是人家就肺齿的那个画面。
所以那天我正好又穿了一双EX Pro嘛，
那个鞋本身你穿上你就忍不住想跑快，
然后我就觉得自己跑得好潇洒呀，
我某某的往下冲，
结果被那个树根犯了一脚。
你看，这不能怪我吧？
你还在这教育品牌有冷静，
你自己上了山都冷静不下来。
真的某某往下冲，
当时觉得自己好帅呀，
然后就吃了个狗吃屎。
希望各大品牌能够吸取ID的教训。
在越野的路上一定不要跑得太快，
否则你可能在下一秒儿弄着要摔根头了。
我还觉得总结好好哦。
好吧，那我们今天的这期播客就聊到这里。
如果你觉得这期节目还不错，
希望能够给我们点一个赞。
如果你是第一次刷到我们的播客，
也希望能够点一个订阅。
这样就可以第一时间看到我们的更新了。
也希望大家能够在社交平台和你的朋友圈里分享我们的播客，
让志同道合的人来跟你一起收听。
那我们今天就聊到这里呀，我是Eddie。
我是Guy。
感谢大家的收听。
我们下期再见。
拜拜。